I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everyone. Hi, you guys. Welcome to Diwali. I'm so excited for this episode, Jenna. Me too. It's a great episode and we have a great special guest. I just want to get to it. All right. Well, this is season three episode six. It was directed by Miguel Arteta and written by our special guest, Mindy Kaling. Very, very exciting. Well, let's get
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正为你们制作终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。嗨，你们好。欢迎来到“排灯节”这一集。我太兴奋了，珍娜。我也是。这一集很棒，而且我们有一位很棒的特邀嘉宾。我只想直接进入正题。好的。嗯，这是第三季第六集。由米格尔·阿特塔执导，由我们的特邀嘉宾敏迪·卡灵编剧。非常非常令人兴奋。好吧，让我们开始吧。
to it. We are going to waste no time. I'm starting with a summary. Do it. In this episode, everyone from Dunder Mifflin attends a traditional Indian celebration of Diwali in honor of Kelly. Now, Ryan is going to meet Kelly's parents, who are really less than impressed with his commitment to their daughter. Well, to be fair, he says with extra money, he wants to travel and get like an Xbox or something. So, you know. Yes. I think I would also be less than impressed. Meanwhile, Michael proposes to his girlfriend, Carol. Oh, Michael. Wow. Oh, Michael. Michael takes a big step in front of a lot of strangers. Yeah. So a bit of a crash and burn. So awkward. Pam enjoys herself for the first time as a single person and
我们不会浪费时间。我先来做个总结。请开始。在这一集中，邓德·米夫林的所有人都参加了为凯利举办的传统印度排灯节庆祝活动。现在，瑞安要去见凯利的父母，他们对他在他们女儿身上的投入程度印象并不深刻。嗯，平心而论，他说有了额外的钱，他想去旅行，买个Xbox之类的东西。所以，你知道的。是的。我想我也会印象不深。与此同时，迈克尔向他的女友卡罗尔求婚。哦，迈克尔。哇。哦，迈克尔。迈克尔在许多陌生人面前迈出了很大的一步。是的，所以有点搞砸了。太尴尬了。帕姆第一次作为单身人士享受自己，而
Angela guards the shoes while eating some dry naan. Very dry naan. And over at the Stamford office, Jim, Andy and Karen work late into the night and booze it up. Yeah. Yeager beister. I mean, what's so gross? Andy is a maniac. I'm going to give you fast fact number one. This is a really special episode because the office was the first American television comedy series to depict the Hindu festival of Diwali. I love that. Way to go, the office. It aired November 2nd, 2006. And it was seen by 8.8 million people on the night that it first aired. And now it's been seen by how many people I don't even know. Did you know what Diwali was, Jenna, when we got the script? Shelby B asked the same question and I did
安吉拉一边吃着干馕一边看守鞋子。非常干的馕。而在斯坦福办公室，吉姆、安迪和凯伦工作到深夜，喝得酩酊大醉。是的。野格炸弹。我是说，这有什么恶心的？安迪是个疯子。我要给你第一个快速事实。这一集非常特别，因为《办公室》是第一部描绘印度排灯节的美国电视喜剧系列。我喜欢这个。干得好，《办公室》。它于2006年11月2日播出。首播当晚有880万人观看。现在已经有不知道多少人看过了。珍娜，当我们拿到剧本时，你知道什么是排灯节吗？谢尔比·B问了同样的问题，而我
not know about Diwali. Did you know about Diwali? I did, but I grew up overseas, you know. I grew up in Indonesia. Diwali has a very big Hindu population. So I had heard of Diwali and I thought it was awesome that we were going to do an episode about it. Had you ever celebrated Diwali? I had never celebrated it, but myself, I went to an international school. They did recognize, you know, many holidays and there was like a Diwali day. Yeah. Well, they do that at my kid's school now. They have a day where they celebrate Diwali, which I think is really cool, especially since I grew up not knowing about it. It is so beautiful and it was so fun. I remember we were all really giddy. Of course this meant
不知道排灯节。你知道排灯节吗？我知道，但我是在海外长大的，你知道。我在印度尼西亚长大。排灯节有非常庞大的印度教人口。所以我听说过排灯节，我觉得我们要拍一集关于它的内容真是太棒了。你曾经庆祝过排灯节吗？我从来没有庆祝过，但我自己上的是国际学校。他们确实认可，你知道，许多节日，而且有类似排灯节的一天。是的。嗯，他们现在在我孩子的学校也这样做。他们有一天会庆祝排灯节，我觉得这真的很酷，尤其是因为我长大时并不知道它。它太美了，而且非常有趣。我记得我们当时都非常兴奋。当然，这意味着
we got to leave the office. That brings me to fast fact number two, Angela. Fan question from Juliet G and Phoebe Tomak. Where did you shoot the scenes when you were celebrating Diwali? Well, guess who I went to for the answer. Does it rhyme with Shmentish Media? It does and we have a sting for it. You do? Yes, Angela, that was sent in by Tyler Beckwith and we love it, Tyler. Thank you for our Kentapedia stage. It is really great. It sounds like something out of like a 1980s action kind of movie. Well, Kentapedia told us that Diwali was shot at Grant High School. We shot most of the scenes in their gym, which is called Grant Hall. We shot there at the end of August and school was in session. They had just started
我们可以离开办公室。这让我想到了第二个快速事实，安吉拉。来自朱丽叶·G和菲比·托马克的粉丝提问。你们庆祝排灯节的场景是在哪里拍摄的？嗯，猜猜我去找谁要答案了？是不是押韵“Shmentish Media”？是的，我们为此准备了一个短语。你有吗？是的，安吉拉，那是泰勒·贝克威斯寄来的，我们很喜欢它，泰勒。谢谢我们的“Kentapedia”舞台。它真的很棒。听起来像是1980年代动作电影里的东西。嗯，Kentapedia告诉我们，排灯节是在格兰特高中拍摄的。我们大部分场景是在他们的体育馆拍摄的，那里叫格兰特大厅。我们在八月底在那里拍摄，当时学校正在上课。他们才刚刚开始
up the school year. He said that we shot there for three full days and we had to work around the school schedule because school was happening in the hallways. I have such a fond memory of our time shooting there because they parked our trailers facing sort of like a little field with some trees and normally they were just in an asphalt parking lot. I would open my door and there would be trees and grass and Brian brought a football and we tossed the football out in the grass and I have such fond memories of this whole week. I remember it too for those exact same reasons. Well, this school is host to a lot of filmmaking, including Freaks and Geeks, Blackish, Malcolm in the Middle and True Blood and I've got
学年。他说我们在那里拍了整整三天，我们必须配合学校的时间表，因为走廊里正在上课。我对我们在那里拍摄的时光有非常美好的回忆，因为他们把我们的拖车停在面对一片小草地和一些树的地方，通常它们只是停在沥青停车场里。我会打开门，外面就是树木和草地，布莱恩带了一个橄榄球，我们在草地上扔橄榄球，我对整个这一周都有非常美好的回忆。我也记得，正是因为同样的原因。嗯，这所学校举办过很多电影拍摄，包括《怪胎与书呆子》、《黑人一家亲》、《马尔柯姆的一家》和《真爱如血》，我还有
a little bit trivia for you. Yeah. Malora Hardin went to Grant High School. Get out of town. Yeah, we shot at her alma mater. Wow. I love that. She's like a true sort of like Hollywood kid, you know? Like there's all these things from her life like right here. To me, it's still all sort of like I still feel like a transplant in some ways in Los Angeles. It's like still to this day, if I'm ever out and about and I see the Hollywood sign, I'm like, there's a Hollywood sign. Oh my God, it's a Hollywood sign. But if I drive by and I see like a film crew filming something on the street, I get as excited as if they pulled up in my neighborhood in St. Louis as a kid. I'm like, oh, what are they filming? Oh, look, I wonder
一点小知识给你。是的。马洛拉·哈丁去了格兰特高中。别开玩笑了。是的，我们在她的母校拍摄。哇。我喜欢这个。她就像一个真正的“好莱坞孩子”，你知道吗？就像她生活中的所有这些事情都在这里。对我来说，这仍然有点像，在某些方面，我仍然觉得自己在洛杉矶是个外来者。就像直到今天，如果我在外面看到好莱坞标志，我还是会说，那是好莱坞标志。天哪，那是好莱坞标志。但如果我开车经过，看到一个摄制组在街上拍东西，我还是会像小时候在圣路易斯时他们开到我家附近一样兴奋。我会说，哦，他们在拍什么？哦，看，我想知道
what it is. I wonder if we can find out who's the star. Yeah, I look like I get that same reaction still. Yeah, me too. I drive by and I try to see is like, is there someone famous out there? Exactly. So true. Well, I'm going to move us along, Angela, because I know we want to get to our interview with Mindy. Fast fact number three, I said earlier this was directed by Miguel Arteta. Angela, I was such a huge fan of Miguel. When I found out he was going to direct this episode, this is the only episode he directed. I completely geeked out. Okay, directed this little go up to him. Were you dorky? What'd you do? Oh, Angela, I followed him around the entire week. We bonded at the end of this week. I thought we were best friends and would work together
那是什么。我想知道我们能不能找出谁是明星。是的，我看起来还是会有同样的反应。是的，我也是。我开车经过，试图看看有没有名人。完全正确。好吧，我要继续了，安吉拉，因为我知道我们想进入对敏迪的采访。第三个快速事实，我之前说过这一集是由米格尔·阿特塔执导的。安吉拉，我是米格尔的超级粉丝。当我发现他要执导这一集时，这是他执导的唯一一集。我完全疯狂了。好的，执导了这个，走过去找他。你表现得笨拙吗？你做了什么？哦，安吉拉，我整个星期都跟着他。我们在这一周结束时建立了联系。我以为我们是最好的朋友，并且会在未来的每一个项目中永远一起工作。而且我不会撒谎。每次有寄给我的剧本，或者当我试图自己制作电影时，他是我第一个会去找的人，因为我当时想，我简直觉得这家伙是个天才。我爱他。我喜欢这个。我不知道你当时到处跟着他。哦，是的，我希望他身上的一切都能感染我。所以他执导过一部叫《查克和巴克》的小型独立电影，由迈克·怀特编剧并主演，顺便说一句，你也是他的痴迷粉丝。是的，我知道，我知道你跟踪过他。我有机会和他一起工作。然后这让我觉得离迈克·怀特更近了一步，我最终跟踪了他并成为了朋友。然后我最终有机会
forever on every future project. And I'm not going to lie. Every time there was like a script that I was sent or when I was trying to produce a movie myself, he was the first person I would go to because I was like, I'm literally like this guy is a genius. I love him. I love that. I didn't know you were like following him around everywhere. Oh, yeah, I wanted everything about him to rub off on me. So he had directed this little indie movie called Chuck and Buck written by and starring Mike White, who by the way, you're also obsessed stocked. Yeah, I know, I know that you stalked him. I got to work with him. And then that made me feel one step closer to Mike White, who I eventually managed to stalk and become I became friends with Mike White. And then I eventually got
出演了一部由本·斯蒂勒主演的迈克·怀特电影。在那之后，我想，好吧，我现在可以退休了，因为我已经和我的偶像一起工作了。我在日记里写了这一周的事。你想听听我写了什么吗，女士？当然，我总是想听听你的日记。你的日记让我很高兴。就是这样。那将是你的自传。《日记让我高兴》，作者：珍娜·费舍。我写了那个，我还写了：我和可爱的敏迪·卡灵将一起在所有当地的NBC电台进行非常早的晨间采访。我们要和16个城市对话。我们必须在早上5点起床。天哪，你们做了一个小小的媒体巡回宣传。我想这是我的第一次。嗯，关于这一点最疯狂的是，安吉拉，
to be in a Mike White movie starring Ben Stiller. And then after that happened, I was like, well, I can I can now retire because I have worked with my my idol. I wrote in my journal about this week. Do you want to hear what I wrote lady? Of course, I always want to hear about your journal. Your journal delights me. That's it does. That's going to be your autobiography. A Journal Delights Me by Jenna Fisher. I wrote that and I wrote this me and the adorable Mindy Kaling are going to be doing really early morning interviews together on all the local NBC stations. We are going to talk to 16 cities. And we have to get up at 5am. Oh my gosh, you guys did a little press junket. I think this is my very first one. Well, what's crazy about that, Angela,
你可能在结束后还得去上班。哦，是的，因为我记得我们必须在舞台上。我们实际上是在片场做的，以片场为背景。我们到了那里，遇到了这个卫星媒体巡回，他们是这么叫的。我们遇到了他们的工作人员。我们必须在凌晨4点到达那里进行化妆和发型。然后我们在早上5点开始采访。我们每15分钟和一个新城市对话，持续了三个小时。哇。是的。而且你这次是和敏迪一起做的。敏迪是我的第一次媒体巡回。嗯，这是一个很好的过渡，进入我们即将到来的环节。我们要休息一下。但当我们回来时，我们将播放对敏迪·卡灵的采访。她来和我们谈了。太棒了。能有她在这里真是太高兴了。
is you probably then after you were done had to come to work. Oh, yeah, because they we had to, I remember we had to be on stage. We actually did them on the set with the set as the background. And we got there and we met this satellite media tour is what they called it. And we met their crew. And we had to be there at 4am to go through hair and makeup. And then we started doing interviews at 5am. And we talked to a new city every 15 minutes for three hours. Wow. Yeah. And now you did it with Mindy. Mindy was my first press junket. Well, this is a wonderful segue into our upcoming segment. We'll take a break. But when we come back, we're going to play our interview with Mindy Kaling. She came and talked to us. It was amazing. It was such a joy to have
而且我非常兴奋让你们听这个。然后之后，我们将全面剖析这一集。休息后我们马上回来。我们和敏迪一起见。敏迪·卡灵。嗨。嗨，你们好。嗨。我很高兴能来到这里。欢迎来到“办公室女士”。我通过Zoom给你们一个拥抱。谢谢。恭喜你们，这个节目取得了巨大的成功。这太棒了。我生活中的每个人显然都是粉丝。我为你们感到骄傲。这太棒了。谢谢。谢谢，敏迪。是的，当然。我们喜欢它。我们玩得很开心。听到你们眼中的节目很有趣，因为它充满了爱、乐趣，而且超级准确。我真的很享受。所以这太棒了。谢谢你们邀请我。
her here. And I'm so excited for you guys to listen to this. And then afterwards, we're going to fully break down the episode. We'll get to that right after the break. We'll see you with Mindy. Mindy Kaling. Hi. Hi, guys. Hi. I'm so happy to be here. Welcome to office, ladies. I'm giving you a hug through the zoomies. Thank you. Congrats, you guys on this massive success of this. This is awesome. Everyone in my life is obviously such a fan. And I'm so proud of you guys. This is so great. Thank you. Thanks, Mindy. Yeah, of course. We love it. We're having a good time. It's fun to hear the way that the show was through your guys' eyes because it's so loving and fun and super accurate. And I'm really enjoying it. So this is great. Thanks for having me.
谢谢。那太好了。我觉得这一切都是纯粹的快乐。看到你并和你交谈，我感到非常高兴。这一集太有趣了。所以我们只是稍微回忆一下。喜欢它。嗯，在我们进入“排灯节”之前，我们总是喜欢问所有嘉宾他们的“办公室起源故事”。那么你是怎么加入这个节目的呢？嗯，那是2004年。我当时在纽约外百老汇演一部叫《马特和本》的戏，那是我和当时的写作伙伴兼朋友布伦达·威瑟斯一起写的，那是一个一小时的短剧，我演本·阿弗莱克，她演马特·达蒙。很难在不觉得尴尬的情况下讲这个故事，所以就忽略那个有趣的细节继续吧。但是
Thank you. That was so nice. I feel like this is all just pure joy. I'm just so delighted to see you and to talk to you. And this is such a fun episode. So we just get to reminisce a little bit. Love it. Well, before we get into Diwali, we always like to ask all of our guests their office origin story. So how did you come to be on the show? Well, it was 2004. And I had, I was doing a play off off Broadway in New York called Matt and Ben, which was a play that I wrote with my writing partner and friend of the time, Brenda Withers, where it's like an hour-long short play where I play Ben Affleck and she plays Matt Damon. It's so hard to tell the story without being like, just being like, okay, so just ignore that kind of interesting fact and move on. But
所以我们做了那个。它赢得了边缘艺术节，获得了一些关注，算是我们进入洛杉矶的入场券。当我们在洛杉矶时，我有一个《发展受阻》的样片，然后就是那部戏。我几乎没有会议。16年前，如果你是一个未经考验的印度裔美国女性，招聘编剧的环境和现在非常不同。我唯一得到面试机会的地方，我得到了两次面试。一个是《Nevermind Nirvana》，这是一个关于印度家庭的试播集。我当时想，是的，我可以，是的，我可以为那个节目写剧本。另一个是《办公室》。我记得乔伊当时，你们记得我们开始拍摄时乔伊有多火吗？是的。哦，是的。《老友记》的衍生剧。我想NBC把他们所有的钱都投在那上面了。
so we did that. It won the Fringe Festival, got some attention and sort of was our entree to LA. And when we were in LA, I had like an Arrested Development spec and then that play. And I had very few meetings. The climate for hiring writers, if you were like an untested Indian-American woman, it was very different 16 years ago than it is now. And the only place that I got an interview at, I got two interviews. One was at Nevermind Nirvana, which was a pilot about an Indian family. And I was like, yes, I could, yes, I could write on that show. And the other one was The Office. And I remember Joey was like, do you guys remember how huge Joey was when we started shooting? Yeah. Oh, yeah. The friend's spinoff. It was like the NBC, I think they put all their money in that.
然后是《父亲的骄傲》。你们记得那个吗？不。那是一部卡通片，杰弗里·卡森伯格制作的卡通片，从两只与齐格弗里德和罗伊一起工作的老虎的角度出发。哦，是的。什么？是的。我想起来了。那是一部动画片。这听起来像是《周六夜现场》里的一个片段。是的。这听起来不像是一个电视节目。它不仅是一个真实的节目，而且还是最火的节目。就像你根本得不到面试机会一样。所以我没能在《威尔和格蕾丝》得到面试，没能在《乔伊》得到面试，也没能在《父亲的骄傲》得到面试。你可以想象，为了展示事情从那时起变得多么不同。你能想象现在一个赢得了边缘艺术节的少数族裔女性来到洛杉矶，
And then Father of the Pride. Do you guys remember that one? No. Father of the Pride was a cartoon, a Jeffrey Katzenberg produced cartoon about from the point of view of two tigers that worked with Sigfried and Roy. Oh, yes. What? Yes. It's coming back to me. And it was an animated show. This sounds like a bit on Saturday Night Live. Yeah. This doesn't sound like a TV show. Not only was it a real show, it was like the hottest show. Like you could not get an interview. So I didn't get an interview on Will and Grace. I didn't get an interview at Joey and I didn't get an interview at Father of the Pride. And you can imagine just to show how things have become so different from then. Can you imagine now a minority woman who won the Fringe Festival coming out to LA,
在两个节目之外得不到一个会议吗？所以这些已经改变了很多。所以这很好。但我得到面试机会的两个人，《Nevermind Nirvana》。我去了他们在伯班克的办公室。这对我来说从未发生过。但我坐在办公室里，当我在那里等待见制片人时，他们接到电话说试播集没有被预订成系列。所以我坐在那里，然后助理出来说，你应该回家了。没有工作。所以我只是起身离开了。第二个是在《办公室》见格雷格·丹尼尔斯。所以我见了他。而且你要知道，我当时的经纪人，我就不提名字了，真的说，是的，这个节目没什么热度。我不认为它真的
not getting a meeting on all the two shows? So these have changed a lot. So that's great. But the two people who I got interviews with never mind Nirvana. And I went into their offices in Burbank. This has never happened to me before. But I sat in the office and as I was there waiting to meet the showrunner, they got the call that the pilot hadn't been picked up to series. So I sat there and then the assistant came out and was like, you should go home. Like there's no jobs. So I just like got up and left. And then the second one was at the office with Greg Daniels. And so I met with him. And just so you know, my agent at the time who I won't mention was really like, yeah, this show doesn't have a lot of heat. Like I don't think it's really
会做出什么成绩。每个人都更喜欢英国版。所以这只是，你知道，见见格雷格·丹尼尔斯很好。他做了很多好事。但就像，只是进行一次一般性的会谈很好。所以我去了那里，并没有太大的赌注。我和格雷格进行了一次非常有趣的面试，持续了两个小时，但你们了解格雷格。所以实际上可能只有15分钟的谈话在两个小时里。然后他雇用了我。或者他没有，他没有在会议中雇用我。他们仍然必须做预展之类的。但我们进行了一次很棒的会议，我听说进展顺利。然后大约一个半月后，我被告知我要回来拍六集，第一季太短了。但我太新了。而且我
going to do anything. Everyone likes the British one better. So it's just like, you know, it's good to meet Greg Daniels. He's like done a lot of good stuff. But like, it's just good to like have a general. So I went in there and there was not a lot of stakes. And I had a very, a really fun interview with Greg that lasted two hours, but you guys know Greg. So it was actually probably only 15 minutes of talking in two hours. And and then he hired me. And or he didn't he didn't hire me in the meeting. Like they still had to do up fronts and everything. But we had a great meeting and I heard it went well. And then like a month and a half later, I was told I was coming back for six episodes, such a small first season. But I was so new. And I
想你们当时，你知道，足够新，以至于就像，哦天哪，任何集数，那太棒了。不知道那是一个异常小的集数。但那就是我加入《办公室》的方式。那你后来是怎么在节目中扮演角色的呢？你知道，格雷格在合同中加入了这些表演条款，我想是针对一些编剧，至少是在我的合同里。我想还有保罗·利伯斯坦的。所以我想在他的潜意识里，他是在那样思考。但第一季经典集《多元化日》，由伟大的BJ·诺瓦克编剧。我记得在房间里，他喜欢这个想法。格雷格喜欢迈克尔·斯科特冒犯所有这些人的想法。
think you guys were, you know, new enough to that it was just like, Oh my gosh, any episodes, that's fantastic. Not knowing that that was kind of an unusually small number of episodes. But that was that was how I got on the office. And how did you end up then playing a role on the show? You know, he had put Greg had put into the contract, these acting, these writing contract, these acting clauses for, I think, a number of the writers, at least it was in mine. And I think Paul Lieberstein's. So I guess in the back of his mind, he was thinking in those terms. But the first season classic episode, Diversity Day written by the great BJ Novak. I remember in the room, he loved this idea. Greg loved this idea of Michael Scott offending all these people.
但当那里也有一些少数族裔时，这才是最有趣的版本，他们可以被额外冒犯。所以当时，我想有另一个少数族裔是有道理的。我就说，我来做。我实际上，我没有自愿。他说，他，我在那一集里有两句台词。他说，你想参与吗？我说，当然。所以《多元化日》，是的，我想天哪，那是第二集，因为那时我想那是开始。我想第一季可能有一两次，我参与得不多。然后第二季就像，我看到，我得到了更多的台词。是的，事情就是这样发生的。让我震惊的是，敏迪，当我回想那个时候，我当时在维基百科上读关于我们所有人和我们当时生活中的位置。你当时24岁。这让我震惊。你当时已经准备好了，对我来说，对于一个24岁的人，你，你太棒了。因为在24岁时，我，我想我当时在Chin Chin's做外卖。我不是服务员。我只是做接待工作。你知道那是什么吗？嗯，谢谢你这么说。我的意思是，我喜欢感觉自己是个神童。但你知道那是什么吗？是编剧的生活，喜剧编剧和演员的生活。它们太不同了，对吧？就像进入喜剧写作很难，但我确实认为这比进入表演更容易。因为如果你能写，你就能写
But it's like, it's kind of the funniest version of it when there's like some minority people there too, who can get extra offended. So at that time, I think it just made sense to have another minority person. And I was like, I'll do it. I actually, I didn't volunteer. He's like, he I had two lines in that episode. And he said, Do you want to be in it? And I was like, of course. And so Diversity Day, yeah, I think Heavens, that was the second episode, because then that I guess starred then. And I think maybe once or twice that first season, I wasn't in it very much. And then second season was like, I sort of saw, I got more lines. And yeah, that's how it happened. What blew me away, Mindy, is when I think back on that, and I was, I was sort of reading back
你自己的机会，写一个样片剧本，你知道，然后你可以使用并寄出去，而当你是一个年轻演员时，你会想，我只是希望有人叫我去试镜。所以谢谢你这么说。但你知道，这也感觉没那么特别，因为BJ在那里，他也是同样的年纪，而且他在24岁时就已经在一个节目里写过剧本了。所以当我当时想，哦，我想我年轻又酷。他就像，哦是的，我已经工作过，他在一个鲍勃·萨格特的情景喜剧里，迈克·舒尔当时28岁，已经拿过艾美奖，并且在《周六夜现场》待了九年或者类似疯狂的事情。所以根本没有那种你会觉得你很特别或者领先于潮流的感觉
on, you know, Wikipedia about all of us and where we are at in our lives at that time. And you were 24. And that blows my mind. You're, you had your act together for, to me, for someone at 24, you, you, you were amazing. Because at 24, I was, I think I was doing takeout at Chin Chin's. I wasn't a waiter. I was just doing a hostess job. Do you know what it is? Well, thank you for saying that. I mean, I love to feel like I was a wonderkin. But do you know what it is? Is that it's just the life of a writer, a comedy writer in the life of an actor. They're just so, they're so different, right? Like it's so, it's very hard to break into comedy writing, but I do think that is easier than breaking into acting. Because if you can write, you can write
和那群人在一起。嗯，我一直觉得你很特别。谢谢。谢谢，安吉拉。好的。我们应该进入这一集吗，珍娜？是的。是的。你有机会重温它吗？是的，我有。重温它对你来说是什么感觉？我必须说，我觉得自己真的很幸运，格雷格想拍这一集，因为它感觉现在，你知道，安吉拉在我最近的节目里，我们做了一集关于象神节的内容，现在有更多，你知道，有更多节目在播出，有多元化的演员阵容等等。但事实上，在黄金时段电视上，我不知道它是哪一年出来的，也许是2007年？它于2006年11月2日播出。它有880万人观看，而且它是
your own opportunities and write a spec script that, you know, then you can use and send out, whereas like when you're a young actor, you're like, I just hope someone calls me in to see something. So thank you for saying that. But you know, it also, it felt less special because BJ is there and he was the same age and he'd already written on a show at 24. So it's just when I was like, oh, I guess I'm like young and cool. He was like, oh yeah, I've already worked on, he was on a Bob Saget sitcom and Mike sure was like 28 and had already had like an Emmy and been an SNL for nine years or something crazy. So there was no sense of like you could ever think you were special or like ahead of the curve or anything
第一部描绘印度排灯节的美国电视喜剧系列。它是第一部。那很酷。那太棒了。为我们这样做点赞。而且你知道，敏迪提到的那个节目是《好想做一次》。敏迪，我确实想在这里给它打个广告，因为它太棒了，演员阵容也很棒，你从一开始就和他们在一起。你找的那些年轻演员，我在那个片场感觉自己有100岁了。我也是。所有17岁的人都一样。天哪。他们太可爱了，而且他们非常喜欢《办公室》。天哪。他们被你迷住了，安吉拉。你能去那里真是太特别了。天哪。敏迪，那个节目的女主角叫什么名字？麦特雷伊·拉玛克里斯南。我崇拜她。哦。因为当你观看那个节目时，你非常
like that with that group of people. Well, I always thought you were special. Thank you. Thanks, Angela. All right. Should we get into this episode, Jenna? Yeah. Yes. Did you get a chance to rewatch it? Yes, I did. What was it like for you to rewatch it? I have to say, I feel really lucky that Greg wanted to do this episode because it feels like now, you know, Angela was on my most recent show and we did an episode about Ganesh Pooja and there's so much more, you know, there's so many more shows on the air with like diverse cast and everything. But the fact that on primetime television, and I don't know what year did it come out, 2007 maybe? It aired November 2nd, 2006. It was seen by 8.8 million people and it was the
立刻就进入了她的旅程。是的。立刻。她太像那种充满活力、开放，而且，哇，真是个发现。真是个发现。谢谢。她会疯掉的。珍娜，《办公室》是她最喜欢的节目。如果你在她的社交媒体上待超过两天，就会有类似《办公室》的梗，或者有类似，是的，我敢打赌你已经在她的Instagram上看到过，比如“请不要向我扔垃圾”。就像一些著名的帕姆台词。好的。所以我们开始吧。现在我们有了排灯节，灯光节。它在电视网上。敏迪，你在电视上真正代表了文化的所有不同方面，你一直都很棒。这只是，你应该知道这对人们意味着什么。我们有很多人写信说，他们的社区
first American television comedy series to depict the Hindu festival of Diwali. It was the very first one. That's cool. That's amazing. Go us for doing that. And you know, the show Mindy's referring to is Never Have I Ever. Mindy, I do want to give it a little plug here because it's so great and the cast is great and you're with them from the beginning. The young actors you got, I felt 100 years old on that set. So did I. So did everyone who was in 17. Oh my god. And they were so cute and they love the office so much. Oh my gosh. They were so starstruck by you, Angela. It was so special that you got to be there. Oh my gosh. Mindy, what is the name of the lead actress on that show? Maitreya Ramakrishnan. I adore her. Oh. Because when you watch the show, you are so
以这种主流方式被看到，这对他们意味着什么。这真的很感人。哦，哇。那太好了。我的意思是，你知道，当你写排灯节这一集时，比较困难的事情之一是，我们不敢相信格雷格答应了，因为通常我们在那一年的那个时候会做类似万圣节的一集，因为那是十月底。但后来我，当他答应时，我不得不面对我是一个印度裔美国人的事实。我对这个节日了解不多。而那种作为印度裔美国人的经历，谈论你对这个节日了解不多，成为了这一集很大的一部分，我喜欢这一点。我喜欢格雷格认为这和我去假装
immediately in with her journey. Yeah. Immediately. She is so like effervescent and open and just, wow, what a find. What a find. Thank you. She's going to flip out. Jenna, she's the office is her number one favorite show. If you go on her social media for more than two days, there's like an office meme or there's like, yeah, I bet you've been on her Instagram like with like, please don't throw a trash at me. Just like some famous Pam line. Okay. So here we go. So now we have Diwali, the Festival of Lights. It's on network TV. Mindy, you have been so amazing at just really, I feel like representing all different sides of culture and on television. It's just, you should know what it's meant to people. We had a lot of people write in about having their community
我和我的家人是印度教节日的专家一样有趣，甚至更有趣。所以我真的很喜欢凯利对它有一种挑衅的态度，即它非常重要，同时也完全不知道它是什么。是的，除了她可以穿一件有亮片的衣服。是的。是的，完全正确。还有音乐部分，她对此真的很兴奋。还有迈克尔在冷开场，我的意思是，敏迪，我喜欢史蒂夫模仿我们作为角色的样子。是的。所以迈克尔就像，嗯，如果你问凯利，就像blah blah，超级好。是的，那个我知道，而且他没能做太多，对吧？就像我觉得他模仿我们模仿得不多。当他模仿时，我只是，它让我觉得很痒。
seen in this mainstream way, what it meant to them. It's really moving. Oh, wow. That's so nice. I mean, you know, the one of the harder things about when you write the Diwali episode is like, we couldn't believe that Greg said yes, because normally we would do like a Halloween episode at that time of year because it's the end of October. But then I, when he said yes, I had to kind of confront the fact that I'm Indian American. I don't know very much about the holiday. And the that experience of being Indian American and talking about how you don't know very much about the holiday kind of became a big part of the episode, which I loved. I liked that Greg thought that was just as interesting, if not more interesting than me going and like pretending
我知道那太搞笑了。我有无数想说的话，珍娜，但去吧，去吧，你来。在这一整集中，我最喜欢的台词之一是这个，“你和那个啦啦队长结婚多久了？”那是你爸爸。天哪，直到今天，我爸爸还会收到支票，他收到版税支票。这就像他的，他最引以为豪的事情。哦，来自《办公室》？是的，当然，对吧？是的。有一次他和我的继母在Erewan，他们被拦住了，有人说，你在《办公室》里，不是吗？那是在他们约会早期，结婚之前。我爸爸当时觉得这太酷了。所以，是的，那就像是一些很好的街头信誉，被认出来了。是的，完全。我只是记得
that like my family and I were these experts at Hindu holidays and everything. So I really like that Kelly is, has this defiant attitude about it that it's really important while also not knowing anything about it at all. Yes, except that she gets to wear like an outfit that has some sparkles on it. Yes. Yeah, exactly. And the music part, she's really excited about that. And Michael in the cold open, I mean, Mindy, I love whenever Steve would do an impression of us as our characters. Yeah. And so Michael's like, well, if you ask Kelly, it's like blah, blah, super fine. Yes, that that I know, and he didn't get to do that that much, right? Like I felt like that he didn't do impressions of us too, too much. When he did, I just, it just got me so tickled.
那是那些集数，你知道，在赛季初，感觉我们做的一件事就是不知何故我们把主要演员中的某个人拉了出来，而某个人在别的地方，那一季是斯坦福。是的。这是其中之一，我真的很喜欢斯坦福的集数。我想有时当我们这样做时，效果很好。有时当我们把他们拉出来时，我们就像，回来吧，我们只是想让你回到主要演员阵容中。但那是一个我觉得效果相当不错的时候。而且我记得当时想，因为我当时在开始时，我想，艾德和约翰在做什么？我想，哦，他们不在那里。是的。所以这很有趣，我只是忘了
I know it was so funny. I have a gazillion things I want to say, Jenna, but go, go, you go. One of my favorite lines in this whole episode is this, how long have you been married to the cheerleader? And that was your dad. Oh my gosh, to this day, my dad gets checks from, he gets residual checks. It's like his, the thing he's the most proud of. Oh, from the office? Yes, of course, right? Yeah. And one time he was with my stepmom at Erewan, and they got stopped and someone was like, you are in the office, weren't you? And that was like early when they were dating before they got married. And my dad was like, felt so cool about it. So, yeah, that was like some good like street cred right there is recognized. Yeah, completely. I just remember
关于整件事。而且我记得我真正喜欢斯坦福的是，那是一群非常有趣的人，即使是那些在斯坦福分部没有大戏份的人。是的，那些我只是觉得我们抓住了那些原型之类的。就像，当我要去那里时，我从不感到无聊。不，它做得太好了。我们谈了一点关于在斯克兰顿片场，像安吉拉和我有一点FOMO（错失恐惧症）和嫉妒，嫉妒他们在斯坦福玩得有多开心，因为每个人都太有趣了。而且，他们每周只需要工作一个半天。没错。超级放松，就像玩得最开心。然后他们有四天假。
that that was like those episodes, you know, at the beginning of the season, it felt like one thing we did a lot was somehow we pulled out someone from the main cast and there was somebody somewhere else and that was Stanford for that season. Yes. And it was one of those ones where I really liked the Stanford episodes. I think sometimes when we did that, it worked really well. Sometimes when we pulled them out, we were like, just come back, we just like want you back in the main cast. But that was a time where I felt like it worked pretty well. And I remember thinking because I was like at the beginning, I was like, what was like what was like Ed and John doing? And I was like, oh, they weren't there. Yeah. So it was it was fun to just I forgot
而我们，我们只是像，嘿，我忘了那一年了。嗯，嗯，珍娜，最好的例子是迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司，那就像，那就像，对我来说，我做过的最喜欢的弧线之一。而且我不认为我为你们写过那里的任何一集。但就像，它有，我想那对人的组合，那群人在他们的任务中，就像，我当时想，哇，这就像，同样，如果不是比任何正在进行的事情更有趣，等等，那是伊德里斯·艾尔巴在的时候吗？是的。是的。嗯，我的意思是，我想如果你切回伊德里斯·艾尔巴，你做得很好。是的。我喜欢在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司。天哪。我有点不想那个弧线结束。还有维克拉姆，你们四个
about that whole thing. And I remember what I really liked about Stanford was like, that was a really funny group of people there, even the people that didn't have big parts like in the Stanford branch. Yeah, those I just thought we nailed those prototypes or whatever. Like, I was never bored when I had to go over there. No, it was so well done. We talked a little bit about having over on the Scranton set, like Angela and I having a little bit of like, FOMO and jealousy of how much fun they were having over on Stanford, because everybody was so funny. And also, they would only have to work like one and a half days a week. That's right. Super relaxed and just like having the best time. And then they got four days off.
在一起。天哪。是的。太棒了。它就像，它本可以成为它自己的电影，就像，你知道，我们现在不是在谈论迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司，我们是在谈论排灯节，但它感觉就像它自己的《少棒闯天下》类型的电影。但你是，你是对的，敏迪，确实有这些配对发生，它们和斯克兰顿发生的事情一样纯粹和美丽。而且，你知道，我买了DVD套装，我看了删除的场景。斯坦福有那么多场景没能放进去。而且就像，那个总是像总是母乳喂养的角色。汉娜会让吉姆非常不舒服。而且至于这一集，我确实有一个问题要问你，因为我
And we were we were just like, hey, I forgot about that year. Well, well, Jenna, the best example of that was the Michael Scott paper company, which was like, which was like, to me, the one of my favorite arcs we've ever done. And I don't think I wrote any of the episodes for you guys there. But like, it has, I think that pairing of people, that group of people on their mission was like, one of the times where I was like, wow, this is just like, equally, if not more funny than like anything that's going, wait, and that's when Idris Elba was was that? Yeah. Yeah. Well, I mean, I guess if you cut back to Idris Elba, you're doing fine. Yeah. I loved being in Michael Scott paper company. Oh, my God. I kind of didn't want that arc to end. And Vikram, the four of you
在和拉什达发短信，她说，这是我非常担心每个人都会讨厌我的一集，因为吉姆和凯伦在停车场里有那种邋遢的亲热。是的，微醺的亲热。它不在删除的场景里。它甚至没有进入剪辑。而且它在拍摄草稿里。哦，是的。拉什达，你们最终拍了吗？因为我也想问那个。当我当时，我有这一集的拍摄草稿，我回去读了它，我当时想，等等，等等，吉姆和凯伦接吻了。是的，他们在接吻。为什么他们在亲热？但后来它在这一集里根本没有，而且也不在删除的场景里。嗯，我有一个记忆，尽管我是现场的编剧，显然，对于
together. Oh, my gosh. Yeah. Amazing. It was so it was like, it could have been its own movie, like, you know, we're not talking about the Michael Scott paper company right now, we're talking about Diwali, but it felt like it was his own bad news bears type movie. But you're, you're right, Mindy, there were these pairings that would happen that were just as pure and beautiful as what was happening in Scranton. And, you know, I got the DVD box set and I watched the deleted scenes. And there's so many scenes at Stanford that never made it in. And like, there's the character that's like, always like was always breastfeeding. Hannah would make Jim really uncomfortable. And then as far as this episode, I do have a question for you because I
这一集，我对此几乎没有记忆。但我会说，我们过去常做的一件事，我觉得很多，就是写推进故事的剧本。然后我们注意到，当我们只有21分半钟来播出这一集时，那种小东西走得很远。就像如果有一个有吸引力的女人在新的环境中工作，她似乎和吉姆有某种融洽的关系，或者他们一起取笑安迪，你会想，哦，那很有趣。就像那可能是某件事。所以感觉我们总是像在撤回那些东西。就像，珍娜，你不觉得你和约翰拍了很多东西吗？那不是像因为你们在那些早期赛季中不是超级像超级调情，就像
was texting with Rashida and she was like, this is the episode I was so worried everyone was going to hate me because Jim and Karen have this sloppy make out out in the parking lot. Yeah, the tipsy make out. It's not in the deleted scenes. It didn't even make that cut. And it was in the shooting draft. Oh, yeah. Did Rashida, did you guys end up shooting that? Because I was going to ask about that too. When I was going, I have the shooting draft from this episode and I went back and I read it and I was like, wait, wait, Jim and Karen kiss. Yeah, they're kissing. Why are they making out? But then it's nowhere in the episode and it's not in the deleted scenes. Well, I have a mind memory, even though I was the writer on set, obviously, for
公开调情，但就像你看着它，你会想，哦，这就像他们，他们用的比我想象的要少，在展示你们那种萌芽的浪漫方面。是的。而且我还要补充一点，有些场景我们会进入。我不知道我是否会称之为争吵，但有些集数里有一些分歧。他们也会撤回那些。而且他们，他们会把它们变小。我想知道它，它很有趣。就像对于节目的很大一部分，在浪漫方面，它总是像少即是多，而对于喜剧，它就像，让我们把托尼·加德纳吊到桌子上。但对于所有那些东西，它，是的，一点点就走得很远。但这些关系是
the episode, I have like zero memory of that. But I will say that one thing that we used to do, I felt a lot was to write scripts that advanced story. And then what we noticed when we only had 21 and a half minutes to air an episode that such like a little one such a long way. Like if there is an attractive woman who is working in the new environment and she seems to have some kind of rapport with Jim or together they're making fun of Andy, you're like, oh, that's interesting. Like that might be something. And so it felt like we were always like pulling back that stuff. Like, Jenna, don't you feel like you shot a lot of stuff with with John? That was like not like because you guys weren't super like super flirty in those early seasons, like
如此巧妙。我觉得它们做得非常聪明。我记得关于这一集我记得很清楚的一件事是，再次，它就像2006年或什么的时光胶囊，因为那个爱情对象，他不是真正的爱情对象，但有一个印度角色，我的父母比瑞安更喜欢他。那只是其中很小的一部分。而且它是由这个编剧瓦利·钱德拉塞卡兰扮演的，他算是节目编剧的朋友，但不是演员，只是一个家伙，就像我们认识的一个家伙。我们的节目有一种真正的随意性，就像，我们只是把它拼凑在一起。是的，我们可能拍了这个。这是第三季，对吧？对于排灯节，它是，我们知道第二季做得很好。我不，我们被提名了
overtly flirty, but like that you watch it and you're like, oh, this was like they they used like less than I thought they would in terms of like showing your guys is like budding romance. Yes. And I would also add that there were some scenes where we would get in. I don't know if I would call it fights, but there were some like disagreements in certain episodes. And they would pull back on those two. And they they would make them smaller. I wonder if it's it's interesting. It's just like for so much of the show, in terms of romance, it was always like less is more, whereas for comedy, it was like, let's hoist up Tony Gardner onto the table. But for all that stuff, it was, yeah, just a little goes a long way. But the relationships were
可能在这一点上。我们有，我们被提名了，但我们不知道。所以我感觉现在我觉得在第三季开始时，我们开始拍摄，我们开始感觉有点像，好吧，我们不会只是被取消或者什么的。因为我记得早些时候有太多的压力，想着就像，当你像，这甚至会持续下去吗时，很难享受一个节目。而且我确实记得从第三季开始，能够多享受一点事情。抱歉，我只是不断地偏离，因为我没有机会谈论《办公室》那么多。我只是，我谈论得非常像，像整体地谈论这个节目，而不是只谈论这一集。但别担心，我们要剖析整个
so finessed. I thought they were so smartly done. One of the things I remember really well about this episode was, again, like it's such a time capsule of like 2006 or whatever, because the love interest, he wasn't really love interest, but there was an Indian character who my parents preferred to Ryan. That was like a very small part of it. And it was played by this writer, Vali Chandrasekharan, who was kind of a friend of the writers on the show, but not an actor, just a guy, like a guy we knew. There was a real sort of casualness to our show of like, we're just kind of putting it together. Yeah, we probably shot this. This is season three, right? For Diwali, it was, we knew that season two had done well. I don't, we'd been nominated
这一集，像进入它的细节。所以这可以是你的《办公室》记忆。我们谈论什么没有处方。是的。好的，酷。格雷格在谈论“酒鬼巡游”，我们只是，我们到处都去了，你知道，但那，这是我们所有人生活中如此特别的一章。我觉得很难把它归类为一集。它是我们如此大的一部分。你知道，我记得很多关于做《办公室》的事情是，我们作为编剧没有意识到格雷格只是说，好吧，嗯，我只是要给编剧世界里的一个人在片场。那将只是这一集的编剧，这有多罕见。有些人现在这样做，但通常是像高层编剧。所以你的工作是确保
probably at this point. We had, we'd been nominated, but we didn't know. So I felt like now I felt like at the beginning of season three, we started shooting, we started feeling like a little bit more like, okay, we're not going to just get canceled or something. Because I remember so much stress earlier on thinking like, it's hard to enjoy a show as much when you're like, is this even going to last? And I do remember being able to enjoy things a little bit more starting like at the beginning of season three. Sorry, I just keep going off of, because I don't get to talk about the office that much. I just, I'm talking really like, like holistically about the show instead of just about this episode. But don't worry, we're going to break down this whole
台词的意图被纠正，给出替代方案，回答演员的问题。我做这个的时候是故事编辑。而且我记得，那相当有压力，我想。就像，我记得在片场，因为米格尔·阿特塔不是我们一直有的导演之一。所以我记得感觉像，这是，像，我是否太像，在片场，因为我们这一集有很多外景拍摄？我当时想，我是否太碍事了？他会对我大喊大叫吗？因为我想第一季，我从来没有一个人拍“辣妹”。就像，我想霍华德和格雷格几乎都在拍摄，因为它是，我想是我们拍的最后几集之一。但对于这一集，它只是像，去管理片场，回答所有印度问题，并确保它非常搞笑。
episode and like get into the nitty gritty of it. So this can be your office memories. There's no prescription for what we talk about. Yeah. Okay, cool. Greg was on to talk about booze crews, and we just, we went everywhere, you know, but that's, it's such a special chapter in all of our lives. I think it's hard to compartmentalize it to one episode. It's such a big part of us. You know, one of the things I remember a lot about doing the office was we didn't realize as writers how rare it was for Greg to just say, okay, well, I'm just going to give one person from the writer's world on set. And that's just going to be the writer of the episode. Some people do that now, but it's usually like an upper level writer. So it's your job to make sure that the intention
这一集，我们深入探讨了细节。所以这可以是你们的《办公室》回忆录。我们聊什么并没有硬性规定。是的。好的，太棒了。格雷格之前来聊过“酒鬼小分队”，我们聊得非常广泛，你知道的，但那确实是我们所有人生命中非常特别的一章。我觉得很难把它局限在一集里。它是我们生命中很重要的一部分。你知道，我记得在做《办公室》时，作为编剧，我们当时并没有意识到格雷格只让编剧团队中的一个人去片场是多么罕见的事。那个人就是那一集的编剧。现在有些人会这样做，但通常是级别较高的编剧。所以你的工作就是确保台词的意图
of the lines is being corrected, give alts, answer questions from the actors. And I was a story editor when I did this. And I remember, like, that was pretty stressful, I think. Like, I remember being on the set because Miguel Arteta was not one of our directors that we had all the time. And so I remember feeling like, is this, like, am I being too, like, on set because we're on location a lot for this episode? I was like, am I too much in his hair? Is he going to yell at me? Because I think season one, I was never alone for hot girl. Like, I think Howard and Greg were there for almost all the shooting, because it was, I think, one of the last ones we shot. But for this one, it was just like, go manage set, answer all Indian questions and make sure it's hilarious
得到正确的传达，提供备选台词，并回答演员的问题。我做这一集的时候还是故事编辑。我记得那压力挺大的。我记得在片场的时候，因为米格尔·阿尔特塔不是我们常驻的导演之一。所以我记得当时感觉，我是不是在片场待得太久了？因为这一集我们有很多外景拍摄。我在想，我是不是太碍事了？他会不会对我大吼大叫？因为我觉得第一季的时候，拍《辣妹》那一集我从没独自待过。我觉得霍华德和格雷格几乎参与了所有的拍摄，因为那好像是我们最后拍摄的几集之一。但对于这一集，感觉就像是，去管理片场，回答所有关于剧本的问题，并确保它足够搞笑。
and do all alts. It's so funny you say that, Mindy, because my impression of you as the writer on set was just always that you were one of my favorites. Really? That's so nice. Oh, yes. Mostly because you were so up to laugh. Like, you found, I always felt like you found everyone hilarious. Oh my gosh. You seemed to like everything. You had the best alts, so you would sort of throw out ideas, maybe based on something you watched us do. You'd be like, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, you have to do that again. Do that again. And then what do you think about saying this? And it was like, oh my gosh, it was just like this uplifting, exciting. That's so nice. Oh, I loved it. I loved it. We've talked a lot about that. And
并做所有的备选台词。Mindy，你说这话真有趣，因为作为编剧在片场时，你一直是我最喜欢的人之一。真的吗？你太好了。哦，是的。主要是因为你总是那么爱笑。我觉得你总是觉得每个人都很搞笑。天哪。你好像喜欢一切。你总有最好的备选台词，你会抛出一些点子，也许是基于我们刚才演的内容。你会说，天哪，天哪，等等，等等，等等，等等，你必须再演一遍。再演一遍。然后你觉得说这句话怎么样？那种感觉就像，天哪，这真是太令人振奋、太令人兴奋了。你太好了。哦，我喜欢。我喜欢。我们谈过很多次了。而且
Jen Slotta was very similar as well. Like, well, Jen, you couldn't get, she just would laugh the whole time. Like, we'd actually have to throw her off because she was laughing too much. She would ruin takes, but yeah. Yeah, I thought, you know, there's this thing that we would do on the show where when a cut would come out, the director's cut, and I've never seen it on any other show, we would all gather and watch it together in the writer's room. And director's cuts famously in other shows like make you want to kill yourself. They're usually so bad, but the quality was so good because the cast was so good. And so I remember it was like my favorite time. We could interrupt all of our work and just go into the little living room area of our writer's room
Jen Slotta也差不多。Jen，你根本没法控制，她会一直笑个不停。我们甚至不得不把她赶走，因为她笑得太多了。她会毁掉拍摄，但确实。是的，我想，你知道，我们在剧组有个习惯，当剪辑版出来时，也就是导演剪辑版，我在其他任何剧组都没见过，我们会聚在编剧室一起看。众所周知，其他剧组的导演剪辑版简直让人想自杀。它们通常很糟糕，但我们的质量很好，因为演员阵容太棒了。所以我记得那是我最喜欢的时光。我们可以中断所有工作，直接走进编剧室的小客厅区域
and watch. I mean, I was such a fan of the show. I watched almost every cut of every episode, and then I would watch it live too. And I didn't realize how unusual that is for somebody who works on a show. Most people do it and then they, a lot of actors don't even watch it when it airs. But I really was such a huge fan of the show. And a lot of times in those conference room scenes, like I'd have like no lines or one line or something in these four page scenes. And to me, it was like going to Second City and just watching everyone just be so funny and just be for free. And you'd be in this like freezing cold room and there'd be snacks every two hours. And I was like, how could this be better? It felt like such an abundance of riches. I just loved
然后观看。我是这部剧的忠实粉丝。我几乎看了每一集的每一个剪辑版，然后我还会看直播。我当时没意识到这对剧组工作人员来说有多不寻常。大多数人做完工作就走了，很多演员甚至在播出时都不看。但我真的是这部剧的超级粉丝。在那些会议室场景中，我经常只有一句台词，甚至没有台词，就在这四页纸的剧本里。对我来说，这就像去了Second City剧团，免费看着大家表演得那么搞笑。你待在一个冷得要命的房间里，每两个小时就有零食。我觉得，还有比这更好的吗？这感觉就像是极其丰富的馈赠。我只是喜欢
sitting and watching everyone in character just reacting. Mindy, I remember one time you were on stage and BJ and you guys were at reception by Jenna and you guys were talking. And I walked up and you were having a conversation about some type of like economics. It was like some kind of like you'd, you'd expanded economics. And I walked up and I was like, I'm going to go over here. I was just like, they are two of the smartest people I've ever met. And I'm going to hard pivot and back away. Wait, BJ and I were talking about economics. We weren't fighting. I'm so surprised. Oh no, you were, it was a heated discussion. You were on opposite sides. That is so funny. Well, I just, I remember you and Paul and BJ as a little trio,
坐着看每个人在角色中做出反应。Mindy，我记得有一次你在舞台上，BJ和你们在Jenna的前台那里聊天。我走过去，你们正在讨论某种经济学。就像是某种你们扩展了的经济学。我走过去，心想，我要去那边。我当时觉得，他们是我见过最聪明的两个人。我要赶紧转头走开。等等，BJ和我当时在讨论经济学？我们没在吵架吧？我很惊讶。哦不，你们在吵，那是一场激烈的讨论。你们站在对立面。太搞笑了。好吧，我只是记得你、Paul和BJ像个小三人组，
probably because you were the writers who were with the actors. So between takes, you guys would always kind of huddle up and talk like story ideas and like what's happening in the writer's room. And so you were having to kind of manage two jobs at once. And I used to like hover around you guys and eavesdrop and just like hope you would invite me in to your hilarious convert. Yes. Some of my favorite memories are listening to you guys discuss story and character and pitch jokes to each other in between scenes. Well, that's so funny because I felt like when we were in the annex, we, you know, we were the writers were in the annex. I'm sure you're sure you guys have talked about this many times, but we were in the annex obviously
可能是因为你们是和演员在一起的编剧。所以在拍摄间隙，你们总是会聚在一起讨论故事构思，还有编剧室里发生了什么。所以你们得同时处理两份工作。我过去常在你们周围徘徊，偷听你们说话，希望你们能邀请我加入你们有趣的谈话。是的。我最美好的回忆之一就是听你们在场景间隙讨论故事和角色，并互相抛出笑话。好吧，这太搞笑了，因为我觉得当我们在附属办公室时，你知道，编剧们都在附属办公室。我相信你们肯定讨论过很多次了，但我们显然在附属办公室
because then we could go be the writer's room and we wouldn't have to be in some of the big group scenes. But I remember also thinking like, but I want to be in the big group scenes. Like I, like those were the funnest scenes to watch when like, you know, Dwight would run in and be like, everyone to the roof. Like we just were left out of those scenes like about Diwali. So here's a couple things that I felt were maybe interesting to say, which was that we only cast my parents in it, which seems just like a complete act of nepotism and favoritism because we had auditioned the parts and Greg had felt that the actors we had found of that age group like the late fifties, early sixties were like a little bit too either theatrical for that style
因为这样我们就可以去编剧室，而不必参与一些大型群戏。但我记得我也曾想过，我想参与那些大型群戏。那些场景看起来最有趣，比如Dwight跑进来喊着，所有人去屋顶。我们被排除在那些场景之外，比如排灯节那集。所以，关于那集，我觉得有几件事可能很有趣，那就是我们只选了我的父母出演，这看起来完全是裙带关系和偏袒，因为我们试镜了这些角色，而Greg觉得我们找到的那个年龄段（五十多岁、六十出头）的演员，要么对于我们剧的表演风格来说太戏剧化了，
of acting on our show or too stilted because they had no acting experience. Now I'm the first to say that my parents acting was also very stilted, but he was like, at least they bear some familial resemblance to you. So we'll just like, we'll just like put them in there. And I don't know if you guys remember this, but I remember going into it. My mom was like, I had this energy of like, I'm just like going to be so much better than, than your father. Like I just know, like neither of them did any acting. She was, she was a doctor. He was an architect, but she had this sense like coming over that she's like, I just hope that you give me the most lines because I'm just naturally better on camera. And like it's going to be good. But then Miguel like fell in love with my dad.
要么因为没有表演经验而显得太生硬。现在，我第一个承认我父母的表演也非常生硬，但他当时说，至少他们和你长得像。所以我们就把他们放进去吧。我不知道你们是否还记得，但我记得在拍摄时，我妈当时那种劲头就像，我一定会比你爸演得好得多。他们俩都没演过戏。她是医生，他是建筑师，但她有一种感觉，觉得她上镜会更自然。她说，我只希望你能给我最多的台词，因为我天生就更适合镜头。这会很棒的。但后来Miguel爱上了我爸。
Like he was like, we have to give him more lines. Like he's killing it. And you guys remember, like this is the show where if anyone ever fell for anyone, Troy El Underbridge, who was like just kind of like a, if anyone was interesting to a director in the wrong reasons, like just because like, oh my God, like I just love that guys look, they could recur on the show for a long time. And I remember being like, I cannot have my dad and my mom come back here like ever again to do this kind of thing. So I remember Miguel Arteta was like, Hey, do you think we can add your dad to the background of like another scene? And I was like, no, we can't. I was going to ask you what it was like for you to have them on set. I was, I don't know if you guys feel this way. Well,
他当时说，我们必须给他更多台词。他演得太棒了。你们还记得吗，这部剧里如果有人爱上了谁，比如Troy El Underbridge，如果导演因为错误的原因觉得某人很有趣，仅仅是因为，天哪，我太喜欢那个人的长相了，他们就能在剧里反复出现很长时间。我记得当时心想，我绝对不能让我爸妈再回来做这种事了。所以我记得Miguel Arteta当时问，嘿，你觉得我们能把你爸加到另一个场景的背景里吗？我说，不，我们不能。我本来想问你，让他们在片场是什么感觉。我不知道你们是否也有这种感觉。好吧，
you don't really. And because like your family, you guys are so tight. So I don't think you have this. But I did not feel so established on the show as a writer or as actor that I felt so comfortable having them there. Like I was really worried about it seeming unprofessional or just like that they would tell boring stories to people. And like Jenna would be like, Hey, can you get this guy away from me? Tell like an ad like I can't hear. I can't hear the story anymore. Like can you please. So I think I was worried and I think I told them like, don't like talk to people at craft services for too long. Like just say hi and answer questions, but don't like launch into you know, other stuff. But that was one thing. I thought they were delightful. We were so excited
你其实不会有这种感觉。因为你们家人关系太紧密了。所以我觉得你不会有这种顾虑。但我当时作为编剧或演员在剧组还没那么稳固，所以我觉得让他们在那儿很不自在。我真的很担心这看起来不专业，或者他们会跟别人讲无聊的故事。Jenna可能会说，嘿，你能把这家伙从我身边带走吗？讲个没完，我听不下去了。你能帮帮我吗？所以我当时很担心，我告诉他们，别在茶水间跟人聊太久。打个招呼回答问题就行，别开始讲其他乱七八糟的事。但有一点，我觉得他们很可爱。我们当时非常兴奋
to have them and they were so cute. Mindy, they were so cute. Well, they're both like five foot four. They're just like both like little, they're both. Yeah, they're my people. I remember your mom complimented my blouse and I remember it. That's nice. She liked the color on me and I was like, Oh, thanks so much. I don't know. I thought they were delightful. And by the way, I thought they're acting was amazing. Thank you. I was watching them in that scene with Steve and I was like, they are killing it. Oh my gosh. Your mom ate him up. Like that was amazing. They were, I mean, I cannot believe because I was at the time where I was like, I'd like to have a scene with Steve, you know, like it felt so special. And here they are. They were like, he's at a crossroads
能让他们来，他们太可爱了。Mindy，他们太可爱了。好吧，他们俩都只有五英尺四英寸高。他们就像两个小人儿。是的，他们是我的家人。我记得你妈妈夸奖了我的衬衫，我记得这件事。那真好。她喜欢我穿的颜色，我说，哦，太感谢了。我不知道，我觉得他们很可爱。顺便说一句，我觉得他们的表演太棒了。谢谢。我当时看着他们和Steve的那场戏，心想，他们演得太好了。天哪。你妈妈完全抢了戏。那太棒了。他们，我是说，我简直不敢相信，因为当时我心想，我也想和Steve演一场戏，你知道，那感觉很特别。结果他们就在那儿。他们当时就像，他在和Carol
with Carol and my dad is like, you should be with her. I don't forget exactly what he said, but I remember being like, this is kind of a juicy scene. But you know, there's a nice little story because like, I feel like Pam stories had such an emotional impact, but they often didn't have like lots and lots of like lines to them, but they always were so impactful as like, I thought your little story in this one was pretty sweet, Jenna. Like it was like, you know, you didn't really want to go. And then you end up having like, I don't know, I thought it was like a nice, I like those kinds of Pam stories. I liked it too. I also, I was really struck by how incredibly good looking David Denman was in this episode. I was like, Pam, Pam, stop for a
处于十字路口，而我爸说，你应该和她在一起。我不记得他具体说了什么，但我记得当时心想，这真是一场精彩的戏。但你知道，这有个不错的小故事，因为我觉得Pam的故事很有情感冲击力，但它们通常没有很多台词，但它们总是很有影响力。我觉得你在这集里的小故事很甜，Jenna。就像，你知道，你其实不想去。然后你最后，我不知道，我觉得那样的Pam故事很好。我也很喜欢。另外，我真的很震惊David Denman在这一集里看起来有多帅。我当时心想，Pam，Pam，停一下，睁开眼睛，看看你面前的人。也许，我是说，也许就为了那一晚重新考虑一下，Pam。就一晚。我当时一直在想这个。是的。David Denman当时也晒得很黑。他真的很，我不知道David在现实生活中在做什么，但他超级黑。是的。他很好地展示了Roy有优点而且长得也帅。所以你不会觉得，这到底是怎么回事？为什么？是的。为什么不是？他长得帅是好事。是的，David Denman绝对是个大帅哥。他得到的赞誉还不够多。是的。伙计们，这太有趣了。既然我已经做到了，而且你们让我感到如此受欢迎，我很乐意以后再回来做一期。
second, open your eyes, see what's in front of you. And just maybe, I mean, maybe just revisit that for one night, Pam. It's one night. That's what, that's what I was thinking the whole time. Yeah. David Denman was also really tan. He was really like, I don't know what David was doing in his real life, but he's super tan. Yeah. He was good to show that Roy had good qualities and was good looking too. So that you weren't just like, what the hell? Like why? Yeah. Why is it not? It's good that he was, yeah, David Denman is a legitimate smoke show. He doesn't get enough credit. Yeah. Guys, this was so much fun. Now that I've done it and you guys made me feel so welcome, I would love to come back and do another one sometime.
我们随时欢迎你回来，Mindy。我敢肯定你已经和剧组其他人谈过这个了。但如果我们以后做“分部战争”那集，Jenna，我有很多有趣的回忆。我记得很清楚的一件事是，通常你会坐在会议室类型的场景里，Michael会是那个让你觉得“我要笑场死掉了”的人。我记得我当时不在，我和你一起在片场，因为那集是我写的，但我显然不是以角色的身份在分部，我不在那儿。我记得当你不得不接替Michael，因为他崩溃了的时候，那是我见过任何剧集中最搞笑的时刻之一。你站在前面，简直是豁出去了，不得不成为Michael那个英勇的助手和朋友。我记得那个。我还记得Michael剪掉了她毛衣的一块。那是我在那一集中最喜欢的两个时刻。哦，谢谢你，Mindy。我玩得很开心。Mindy，非常感谢你。见到你真是太高兴了。非常感谢。真的很有趣。很高兴见到你。是的，伙计们，祝你们，我是说，祝你们好运，但你们不需要好运。你们已经是，这是有史以来排名第一的播客。别说了。顺便说一句，说到这个，我简直不敢相信。好吧，我三岁了。我太兴奋了。谢谢。我们非常爱你，Mindy。好的，再见。再见，Mindy。再见。我们回来了。Mindy Kaling。太有趣了。请再来。那真是太棒了。我们必须让她
We will have you back anytime, Mindy. I really, I'm sure you already did this and talked about it with somebody else in the show. But if we ever do branch wars, Jenna, I have so many funny memories of it. Like one thing I remember really well was normally you'd sit in a conference room type scene and Michael would be the person that would just be so funny that you felt like I'm going to break and die. And I remember I was not, I was on set with you because I'd written the episode, but I was not obviously at the branch on like as a character, I wasn't there. And I remember when you had to take over for Michael because he was had like a breakdown, that was like some of the funniest moments of any episode I'd ever seen. Like you in front of like just eating it and having
回来。我知道。好了，女士们，我们要拆解这一集吗？我们刚才聊了一点关于Mindy的那个冷开场。我们在办公室开场。Kelly在帮Ryan整理他的库尔塔长衫。Michael进来了，他开始嘲笑它。他管它叫裙子，对吧？但后来Pam和Kelly都在夸Ryan看起来有多帅。Michael突然希望自己也有一件。他真是个孩子。他说，你怎么没给我买一件？我想你能看到Mindy在他这么说时开始笑场了。我当时想，那是即兴台词吗，Jenna？不，那是剧本里的。因为我觉得你能看到Mindy开始做她那种笑场。她是感到惊讶吗？不，那只是Mindy因为你说了那些话而笑场，
to be like this valiant assistant and friend to Michael. I remember that. And I also remember Michael cutting a piece of her sweater off. Those were the, those were my two favorite moments of that episode. Oh, thank you, Mindy. I had a great time. Mindy, thank you so much. It was such a joy to see you. Thank you so much. It was really fun. Great to see you. And yeah, guys, good, I mean, I was going to say good luck, but you don't need good luck. You're already, this is the number one podcast ever. But stop it. By the way, speaking of, I can't believe legally. Well, I'm three. I'm so excited. Thank you. We love you so much, Mindy. Okay, bye. Bye, Mindy. Bye. And we are back. Mindy Kaling. So fun. Please come back. That was so great. We have to have
这是Mindy以前喜欢做的事。好吧，现在我们有一个派对策划委员会的场景。伙计们，我们太喜欢这些场景了。每当剧本里有这个，我们都会乐不可支。我觉得很有趣的是，在这个派对策划委员会场景里，有Ryan、Meredith、Pam、Angela和Phyllis。他们正在讨论谁和谁拼车。有一张图表。显然，他们根本策划不了这个派对。他们是被邀请的客人。所以他们必须找点事来策划。于是他们在策划拼车。这就是Phyllis写在白板上的。在Bob的Yukon车里，她很自豪地说他有一辆Yukon，会有Phyllis、Stanley、Angela、Kevin和Pam。而在Meredith的面包车里，会有Meredith、Daryl、Lonnie、Creed、Ryan和Kelly。
her back. I know. All right, ladies, should we break down this episode? We talked a little bit about this cold open with Mindy. We open in the office. Kelly is helping Ryan with his curta. And Michael enters and he starts laughing at it. He calls it a dress, right? But then Pam and Kelly gush about how handsome Ryan looks. And Michael suddenly wishes that he had one too. He's such a child. He's like, how come you didn't get me one? I think you can see Mindy starting to break when he says that. And I wondered if that was an improvised line, Jenna. No, it's in the script. Because I feel like you can see Mindy starting to do that break that she does. Like she was taken by surprise? Yeah. No, that's just Mindy breaking because you said words,
现在，拼车名单里少了谁？Oscar。他在休假。Michael和Dwight，谁和Michael与Dwight一起坐车？我想他们是自己走吧。是的，好问题。好吧，我想Michael和Carol会一起去。但Dwight是怎么去的？他一个人。他一个人。但我希望你们知道有一个很棒的删减片段。这个派对策划委员会场景有一个加长版。太搞笑了，因为Angela不想让任何人去。我其实有一个采访镜头，解释了为什么我那么反对排灯节。其实并不是关于排灯节。是因为我觉得Dwight可能对Kelly还有意思，或者也许那里会有他感兴趣的其他人。所以我真的有这种态度，听着，我其实有
which is what Mindy used to like to do. Well, now we have a party planning committee scene. You guys, we lived for these. We got so tickled whenever there was one in the script. I find it fascinating that in this party planning committee scene, it is Ryan, Meredith, Pam, Angela and Phyllis. And they are discussing who's going to carpool with who. There's a chart. Clearly, they couldn't plan this party. They were invited guests. So they had to have something to plan. So they're planning carpools. This is what Phyllis wrote on the dry erase board. And Bob's Yukon, and she was very proud to say that he had a Yukon in Bob's Yukon, would be Phyllis, Stanley, Angela, Kevin and Pam. And Meredith's minivan would be Meredith, Daryl, Lonnie, Creed, Ryan and Kelly.
这句台词，我说办公室里有些人对来自印度的事物太着迷了。是的。所以她在吃醋。这就是她贯穿始终的滤镜。这就是为什么她一直那么刻薄。然后Jenna，我喜欢的是她试图劝说大家不要去。Ryan说，Kelly挺感兴趣的。我想我们可以去。然后他说，我不在乎。其实，我们可以不去。我不在乎。Ryan说，你们想让我不去，行啊。我们确实收到了很多邮件，问为什么Angela对这个节日这么刻薄。所以我很高兴你分享了那个删减片段，因为有一个额外的故事情节，你和我想你能在场景里稍微看出来一点，
Now, who is missing from the carpool Oscar? He's on leave. Michael and Dwight, who's riding with Michael and Dwight. They're on their own, I guess. Yeah, good question. Well, I guess Michael and Carol are going to go together. But how did Dwight get there? He's solo. He's solo. But I want you guys to know there is a fantastic deleted scene. There's an extension of this party planning committee scene. And it's so funny because Angela doesn't want anyone to go. And I actually have a talking head where it sort of sets up why I'm so against Diwali. And it's not really about Diwali. It's because I think Dwight might still have a thing for Kelly, or maybe there'll be someone else there he might be interested in. So I really have this attitude that, listen, I actually have
Pam告诉Kelly她可能不去，诸如此类，然后你的头冒了出来。哦，是的。在那个隔板后面。当Dwight以那种权威的口吻说他是单身时，你确实有点吃醋。他没和任何人约会。是的。因为Kelly建议如果Pam不想一个人去，可以和Dwight一起。她说，你是单身，对吧，Dwight？Dwight说，哦，是的，我完全单身。我想你就在那儿看到了Angela的那点嫉妒，哦，我不喜欢这样。有一些删减片段确实演绎了这个Dwight和Angela的故事线以及她的嫉妒，还有它是如何解决的。但这就是Angela Martin当时的心态。所以Michael意识到人们可能不像他希望的那样
this line where I say certain people in this office are a little too obsessed with things from India. Yes. So she's jealous. And that's really her filter through all of this. That's why she's so salty all the way through. And then Jenna, what I love is she's trying to like talk people out of going. And Ryan was like, well, Kelly's kind of into it. I thought we could go. And then he's like, I don't care. Actually, we can bail. I don't care. Ryan was like, you guys want me to bail fine. We actually got a lot of mail wondering why Angela was so salty about this festival. And so I'm really glad you shared that deleted scene because there was this whole extra storyline element that it's you and I think you kind of see it a little bit in the scene
对这个排灯节充满热情。他说他认为这是因为，你知道，人们对其他文化太无知了。他真的不想在女朋友Carol面前因为大家的无知而感到尴尬。是的。所以他必须教育大家。这意味着我们都要去会议室。是的。再一次，Michael从哪儿弄来的这些海报？感觉很仓促，但他却有这么多海报。他是不是派Dwight去疯狂采购了？我们一进会议室就有各种各样的海报。确实如此。当他开始给我们看这个幻灯片时，你注意到有一张Michael和Carol尴尬接吻的照片不小心出现在了演示文稿里。
where Pam is telling Kelly, she might not go and this and that and your head has popped up. Oh, yeah. Behind that partition. And you are a little jealous when Dwight with such authority says he's single. He's not seeing anyone. Yes. Because Kelly suggests maybe Pam go with Dwight if she doesn't want to go alone. And she's like, you're single, right, Dwight? And Dwight's like, oh, yeah, I'm totally single. And I think that's you see that little jealousy right there from Angela like, ooh, don't like it. There's deleted scenes that really sort of play out this Dwight Angela storyline and her jealousy and how it resolves itself. But that that's what was going on for Angela Martin. So Michael gets aware of the fact that people might not be as
是的。好吧，然后他给员工们分发了《爱经》。记住，Angela，那是Phyllis不得不打印并装订成册的那些《爱经》姿势小册子。它们在电视上被模糊处理了，但在现实生活中没有。我们作为演员都坐在房间里。我们拿到了这些小册子。我记得当时完全是，哦，哦，哇。好吧。当然，Kevin说这是他们开过最好的会议。最好的一次。如果你们有机会重看这一集，在最后，Toby收走了《爱经》。我想让你们看看Phyllis的脸，因为她做了一个表情，好像因为丢了书而感到非常沮丧。
enthusiastic about this Diwali festival as he would like. He says he thinks it's because, you know, people are just ignorant about other cultures. And he really does not want to be embarrassed by everyone's ignorance in front of his girlfriend, Carol. Yeah. So he's got to educate everyone. So this means we're all going in the conference room. Yes. Once again, where does Michael get these posters? It feels last minute, but yet he has all these posters. Does he send Dwight on like a mad dash? There's all kinds of posters once we get in the conference room. It's so true. And when he starts showing us this slideshow, you notice how there's a photo of Michael and Carol kissing awkward that accidentally makes its way into this presentation.
天哪，我错过了那个。哦，我迫不及待想回去看看。好吧，Angela，我们要聊聊Stamford那边发生了什么吗？你是说Josh Porter的骑行短裤和他的花哨自行车，还有Jim和他那辆带大篮子的笨重自行车？Jim怎么了？发生了什么？好吧，Jim开始像Josh一样骑车上班了。他说，我要省油钱。这能让我保持身材。他没预料到自己会出那么多汗。那个采访镜头太搞笑了。他们在他身上弄了多少汗水。Angela，你还记得他们过去是怎么让我们出汗的吗？当你必须出汗的时候？他们喷你。是的，他们要么用那种喷植物的瓶子喷你，要么用那种
Yeah. Well, then he passes out the Kamasutra to the employees. And remember, Angela, that was those were like little booklets that Phil Shea had to put together in print of all these Kamasutra positions. And they were blurred out for television, but they were not blurred out in real life. We're all like, we're all sitting in the room as actors. And we get these little booklets. And I remember being totally like, Oh, oh, wow. Okay. Of course, Kevin says this is the best meeting they've ever had. The best one. If you guys get a chance and rewatch the scene, at the end, Toby takes away the Kamasutra. And I want you to look at Phyllis's face, because she makes an expression like she's really bummed out to lose the book.
Evian喷雾喷你，他们得在腋下喷。但他们必须在每次拍摄间隙都来喷，因为汗会干。但有时他们会在你的发际线周围涂上婴儿油，然后再喷，这样看起来会特别出汗。我刚刚给了大家一点关于如何让演员出汗的内幕信息。你们可以在家试试。我只是在笑你刚才说了多少次“出汗”。出汗。好吧。现在在4分23秒，Sam，你能播放Mustang吗？调情的Karen。调情的Karen。那是我的妈妈，Bertie Kinsley。调情的Karen。Karen说，嘿，篮子不错。自从薯片事件以来，她就迷上他了。是的。所以然后
Oh my gosh, I missed that. Oh, I can't wait to go back and see that. Well, Angela, should we talk a little bit about what's going on in Stamford? You mean with Josh Porter's like biker shorts and his fancy bike and Jim and his clunky bike with a big basket? What's happening, Jim? What's going on? Well, Jim has started biking to work just like Josh. He says, I'm going to save gas money. It keeps me in shape. He did not anticipate how sweaty he would be. That talking head is so funny. How much sweat they put on him. Angela, do you remember how they used to make us sweaty when you have to be sweaty? They spray you. Yeah, they would either spray you with like a bottle that you would mist your plants with or they would spray you with like those
Josh走过来给了Karen公司信用卡，因为他们得加班，可以买晚餐。但他说了，这次每人不超过20美元。这次，每人20美元。我们是在2006年拍摄的。有什么外卖是每人超过20美元的吗？嘿，也许Stamford没能坚持下去是有原因的。我是说，天哪。我不知道。也许我只是不点太高档的外卖。但我觉得在2006年，要点一份每人超过20美元的餐点对我来说是个挑战。是的。特别是在Scranton的深夜。他们点了什么？你知道，比如泰国菜。我知道。没错。这并不难。不过Andy拿出了野格酒。
Evian mist sprays and they have to like spritz you under the arms. But then they'd have to come and do it like between every take because it would dry. But then sometimes they would put like baby oil around like your hairline and then spray you so it would look especially sweaty. I've just given everybody a little inside info on how you make an actor sweaty. You can try it at home. I'm just laughing at how many times you just said sweaty. Sweaty. All right. So now at four minutes, 23 seconds, Sam, will you play Mustang? Flirty Karen. Flirty Karen. That's my mom, Bertie Kinsley. Flirty Karen. Karen says, hey, nice basket. Ever since the whole chips incident, she's smitten. Yep. So then
他有别的计划。他准备好狂欢了。Ed Helms举起那瓶野格酒和酒杯时的表情太搞笑了。你看到了Andy在大学时是什么样，你会想，哦，伙计。好吧，回到Scranton，事情变得令人兴奋了，因为每个人都来到了排灯节。他们到了。他们走进来。真的很亮，色彩鲜艳，还有音乐在响。Phyllis说，脱鞋不是很有趣吗？Angela说，我希望不是每个人都脱鞋。Kevin说，别说了。我告诉过你这是条件。所以你们记得在“悲伤辅导”那集，我们谈过一个删减片段，本该出现在那一集里，关于Angela和Kevin
Josh comes over and gives Karen the company credit card because they have to work late and they're allowed to buy dinner. But he says, you know, no more than $20 a person this time. This time, $20 a person. We shot this in 2006. Is there a meal out there that you order that's more than $20 a person? Hey, maybe there's a reason Stanford doesn't make it. I mean, my gosh. I don't know. Maybe I just don't eat at very fancy places for my takeout. But I feel like I would be challenged to order a meal for more than $20 a person in 2006. Yeah. Especially like late at night in Scranton. What are they getting? You know, like Thai food. I know. Exactly. This is not difficult. Andy, though, busts out some Jagermeister.
又因为他出汗的脚吵起来了。是的。这是对删减片段的呼应。所以大多数观众会忽略它，但那些观看删减片段的铁杆观众会知道这意味着什么。我觉得编剧室里有人真的下定决心要确保我们有关于Kevin脚的场景。我觉得墙上有一张便签写着“Kevin出汗的脚”，有人很喜欢它，一直想把它放进剧集里。好吧，这是Angela的噩梦，人们脱掉所有的鞋子，更不用说Kevin出汗的脚了。我是说，这根本不是她想参加派对的方式。不，不。所以Angela，我们收到了一个关于这些排灯节场景的粉丝提问。来自Sarah Beth Miller。
He's got other plans. He's ready to party. Ed Helms' face when he holds up that Jagermeister bottle and the shot glasses is hilarious. You get a window into who Andy was in college and you're like, oh, buddy. Well, back in Scranton, things are getting exciting because everyone is showing up to Diwali. They're arriving. They're walking in. It's really, really like bright and colorful and there's music playing. And Phyllis is like, isn't it fun to take our shoes off? And Angela is like, I wish not everyone took their shoes off. And Kevin's like, stop it. I told you it was a condition. So you guys remember in grief counseling, we talked about a deleted scene that would have been in the episode where Angela and Kevin
她问，拍摄这一集时，这真的是一场真正的排灯节庆祝活动吗？你们是怎么弄到那么多穿着漂亮服装的人的？好问题，Sarah Beth。我是说，这个场景里有很多人。所以情况是这样的，这不是真正的排灯节。那是我们出色的剧组专门为这一集搭建的。是的，我们的布景设计师Michael Gallenberg和他的团队，他们装饰了整个体育馆。Michael必须做大量的研究，才能把体育馆改造成感觉像真正的排灯节。所以我认为他会很自豪地知道你怀疑这是不是真的。就像，也许我们只是走进了一个现有的节日。不，他们把整个场景都做出来了。
go off again about his sweaty feet. Yes. This is a callback to a deleted scene. So it's going to go unappreciated by most viewers, but those diehard viewers who watch those deleted scenes will know what this means. I feel like someone in the writer's room was really determined to make sure we had scenes about Kevin's feet. I feel like it was a note card on the on the wall that said Kevin's sweaty feet and someone loved it and kept wanting to get it in the episodes. Well, this is Angela's worst nightmare, people taking off all their shoes, even minus Kevin's sweaty feet. I mean, this is just not how she wants to be at a party. No, no. So Angela, we got a fan question about these Diwali scenes. It comes from Sarah Beth Miller.
他们做得太棒了。至于服装，我的角色没能打扮。Jenna，我太沮丧了。是的。你知道，我是说，她其实只是穿着上班穿的衣服。她甚至没换掉工作服。我知道。但有些演员确实打扮了。BJ、Rainn、Mindy，我相信我们的服装造型师很高兴能做点除了沉闷的办公室装束以外的事情。每次我们能穿除了办公室装束以外的衣服时，他们都会非常兴奋。Pam没怎么打扮，但她没穿办公室装束，这很有趣。我为此专门试装了一次。我们看到了休闲版的Pam。你注意到我的发型也变了吗？但我们确实发现了一些关于其他
She asked, was this a real Diwali celebration happening in the filming of this episode? How did you get all of those people in those beautiful costumes? Great question, Sarah Beth. I mean, there are so many people in this scene. So here's the thing, it was not a real Diwali festival. That was all put together by our amazing crew just specifically for this episode. Yes, our set designer, Michael Gallenberg and his team, they decorated that whole gym. Michael had to do a lot of research in order to transform the gymnasium to feel like a real Diwali festival. So I think he would be very proud to know that you wondered if this was real. Like, maybe we just stepped into an existing festival. No, they made the whole thing.
为这个节日打扮的背景演员的有趣花絮。是的，我们去了Kintopedia，他说我们的选角办公室与Central Casting合作。现在，Central Casting是洛杉矶的一家选角机构。他们专门负责背景演员和填充画面，对吧？是的。Central Casting联系了洛杉矶的许多印度社区，雇佣了那些背景演员。总而言之，Kent说我们这一集雇了100名临时演员。他们每个人都带来了自己非常漂亮的服装供我们使用。为了充实这个世界，Kent还雇佣了一家专业的舞蹈公司来带领我们跳一些舞。他找到了一家叫NDM Dance Productions的公司，并雇佣了他们的导演兼编舞，
They did a fantastic job. As far as costumes go, my character did not get to dress up. Jenna, I was so bummed. Yeah. You know, I mean, she actually is just wearing what she wore to work. She didn't even change out of her work clothes. I know. But some of the cast did get to dress up. BJ, Rain, Mindy, and I'm sure our wardrobe stylist was thrilled to do something other than just drab office attire. They used to get so excited every time we got to wear anything other than our office attire. And Pam didn't really dress up, but she is not in her office attire, which was fun. I had a whole separate fitting for that. We got to see casual Pam. And did you notice I got to wear my hair differently as well. But we did find out some interesting trivia about all the other
Dev Mahajan。Dev雇了八名舞者。他在拍摄第四天的早上编排并排练了他们的舞蹈，那天我们拍摄了所有的舞蹈。然后我们在下午拍摄。所有的舞者也穿了他们自己的服装。我其实去了那个网站。你当然去了，Lady。你去了舞者的网站。你发现了什么？他们出现在无数节目中。所以你认为你能跳舞、E Live奥斯卡报道、早安美国、舞蹈巨星和MTV的美国最佳舞蹈团。如果你想查他们，可以在ndmdance.com找到他们。这太酷了，它最终真的感觉像一个真正的派对，像一个真正的庆祝活动。确实如此。我希望我的角色能更多地参与其中，因为我，
background actors who were dressed up for this festival. Yes, we went to Kintopedia and he said our casting office worked with Central Casting. Now, Central Casting is a casting agency in Los Angeles. They specialize in sort of the background actors and filling out the picture, right? Yeah. Central Casting reached out to a lot of the Indian community here in Los Angeles to hire those background players. All in all, Kent said we had 100 extras working this episode. And every single one of them brought their own very beautiful costuming for us to use. And to kind of fill out the world, Kent also hired a professional dance company to come and lead us in some of the dances. He found a company called NDM Dance Productions and he hired their director choreographer,
Angela，那就是我，本来会就在那儿玩得很开心。所以，在这些时刻不能穿上戏服、不能参与其中、只能做墙边的那个扫兴鬼，总是很难受，你知道吗？我懂。我们稍后会谈谈我的舞蹈，但我确实跳了一点，我非常兴奋。非常有趣。好吧，所以是的，有些人能打扮，有些人不能。Michael和Carol带着对这个派对完全不同的想法走了进来。Michael显然告诉Carol这是一个化装舞会，所以她穿着啦啦队服来了。带着啦啦球。带着啦啦球。而Michael穿着他旧的万圣节服装。他戴着那个纸糊的头套。我们收到了Melinda O'Brien的粉丝提问，
Dev Mahajan. And Dev hired eight dancers. He choreographed, rehearsed their dance in the morning of that day four of shooting is when we shot all the dancing. And then we filmed it later in the afternoon. And all the dancers were their own costumes as well. I actually went to the website. Of course you did, Lady. You went to the dancers website. What'd you find out? They have appeared on tons of shows. So you think you can dance, E Live Oscar coverage, Good Morning America, Superstars of Dance and MTV's America's Best Dance Crew. If you want to look them up, you can find them at ndmdance.com. It was super cool and it really did end up feeling like a real party, like a real celebration. It really did. I wish my character wanted to participate more because me,
Michael的服装是万圣节那集里的同一件吗？还是他们不得不又做了一件？哦不，Melinda，我们保存了一切。办公室里任何人穿过、拿过、用过或互动过的任何东西都会进入一个巨大的仓库。它被贴上了标签。几乎就像一个证据室。所以当他们把这个写进这一集时，他们只是去了那个仓库，拿起了那个纸糊的头套，又把它戴回了他的肩膀上。没错。就像《夺宝奇兵》的结尾。就像一排排贴着日期、标签、剧集名称的箱子。所以他们直接去了那个箱子。当然，Michael，你知道，他可以把头套拿下来，然后他看起来就像穿着西装，但Carol现在被困住了，
Angela, that is me, would have been right out there like just having a great time. So it was always hard in these moments to not get to be in costume and not participate and be kind of the grump on the wall, you know? I do. And we'll talk a little bit about my dancing later, but I did get to dance a little bit and I was thrilled. Very fun. All right, so yeah, so there are people that got to dress up, people that didn't. Michael and Carol walk in with a whole different idea of what this party is. Michael has clearly told Carol that this is a costume party, so she arrives dressed as a cheerleader. With pom poms. With pom poms. And Michael has his old Halloween costume on. He has his paper mache head. We had a fan question from Melinda O'Brien,
因为Michael以为这是印度万圣节。是的，我知道。可怜的Carol。她在这一集中表现得太好了。她不得不忍受这么多。Nancy Krill演得太完美了，她那种安静地忍受这个尴尬夜晚的同时还穿着啦啦队服的样子。是的。好吧，让我们转到自助餐区。Angela在自助餐区。她问他们有没有素食选择。当她得知一切都是素食时，她似乎并不满意。全是素食。她完全处于扫兴模式。她说，给我点面包就行。然后那个人用手把面包递给了她。Angela，你在这里有一句台词，我
was Michael's costume the same one from the Halloween episode or did they have to make another one? Oh no, Melinda, we save everything. Everything that anyone wore or held or used or interacted with on the office goes into a giant warehouse. It's tagged. It's almost like an evidence room. So when they wrote that into this episode, they just went to that warehouse and they picked up that paper mache head and put it right on his shoulder again. That's right. It's like the end of Raiders of the Lost Ark. It's like rows and rows of boxes with dates, tags, episode names. So they went right to that box. And of course, Michael, you know, he can take the head off and then he just looks like he's in a suit, but Carol is stuck now
相当确定你是即兴发挥的。哦，是的。我看到了。你走开时用了你的手。我确实即兴发挥了，因为那个人确实是用手递给我的。我想，那不好。你应该用夹子。用夹子。他只是用手递给了我。所以我即兴说了那句台词，它被保留了下来，这让我发笑。当然，她还是吃了。所以我猜她并不太担心。但很明显她玩得不开心。而且她有点恶心，因为她看到了很多脚。现在一个人又用手递给她面包。一个陌生人。好吧，剧本里说你咬了一口然后说，大蒜。我们收到了一些关于食物的粉丝提问。Stacy和Rutby都
as a cheerleader because Michael thought this was Indian Halloween. Yes, I know. Poor Carol. She is such a sport in this episode. She has to endure so much. And Nancy Krill just knocked it out of the park. She plays it so perfect of just sort of like quietly enduring this awkward evening while dressed like a cheerleader. Yeah. Well, let's move over to the buffet. Angela's at the buffet. She asks if they have any vegetarian options. She doesn't even seem satisfied when she learns that everything is vegetarian. It's all vegetarian. She's just in full grump mode. She's like, just give me some bread. And then the guy hands her the bread with his hands. And Angela, you have a line here that I am
写信来说，那些看起来很美味的自助餐食物是真的吗？拍摄这一集时你们尝过那些菜肴吗？伙计们，那全是真食物。全是真实的。全都很美味。Kent告诉我，我们雇了一位专业食品造型师来制作那些食物，它们是地道准备的。我们拍摄的三天里都有这些食物，我们都能吃。我记得它很美味。它很美味。我只吃了馕，但那是很好的馕。哦，我在拍摄间隙吃了。我只是吃了它。你甚至没在屏幕上看到Pam吃它。我当时想，我会吃这个。好吧，现在我们来到了这一集中我最喜欢的时刻之一，Angela。这是Ryan见到Kelly那些咯咯笑的姐妹们的时候。是的。太可爱了。我们收到了一些
fairly certain you improvised. Oh yeah. I see. You used your hands as I walk away. And I did improvise that because the guy literally did hand it to me with his hands. And I thought, that's not good. You shouldn't use some tongs. Some tongs. He just handed it to me with his hands. And so I improvised that line and it stayed in and it makes me laugh. Of course, she goes ahead and eats it. So I guess she's not too concerned. But it's clearly she's just like not having a good time. And she's a little like grossed out because she's seeing a lot of feet. And now a guy just handed her bread with his hands. A stranger. Well, in the script, it says that you take a bite and say, garlic. We had some fan questions about the foods. Stacy and Rutby both
来自Lindsay、Bridget和Dan的粉丝提问，他们都想知道，Kelly的姐妹们在和Ryan说话时到底在说什么？她们在说关于Zach Braff的事。好的。这三个小女孩说的是，Kelly喜欢Zach Braff。她们用印地语说的就是这个。她们有点像在逗他。她们太可爱了，分别由Tanvir Atwal、Ananya Kepper和Jaysha Patel饰演。好吧，那个说Zach Braff台词的Kelly姐妹的小女孩，那是Jaysha。我在Instagram上找到了她，我联系了她，问她参演这部剧是什么感觉，她回信了。我迫不及待想分享。她现在一定是个成年女士了。她现在是个成年女性了。她告诉我，拍摄这一集时她才13岁。
wrote in to say, was any of that delicious looking buffet food real? Did you get to sample some of the cuisine while filming this episode? Guys, it was all real food. It was all real. It was all delicious. Kent told me we hired a specialty food stylist to create the food that it was authentically prepared. And we had it all three days of filming and we got to eat it. And I remember that it was delicious. It was delicious. I only got to eat the naan, but it was very good naan. Oh, I ate between takes. I just ate it. You don't even see Pam eating it on screen. I was like, I will eat this. Well, now we come to one of the moments in this episode that is one of my favorites, Angela. This is when Ryan meets Kelly's giggly sisters. Yeah. It's so, so cute. We got some
她说她没怎么听说过这部剧。她说她当时还在看迪士尼频道。但她说她爸爸带她去试镜，她记得走进选角办公室，看到成堆的其他孩子都在竞争同一个角色。她说试镜只是让她用印地语说那一句台词，她说她根本不会说印地语。所以她爸爸在进试镜室前五秒钟告诉她怎么说，然后她就得到了这个角色。所以她说她当时太兴奋了，我问她如果在片场有什么回忆，她发回了最甜蜜的信息。所以我们现在就为你们播放。我记得Rainn Wilson走过来，把一把光剑塞进我手里，大喊光剑大战。我还
fan questions from Lindsay Bridget and Dan who all want to know, do you know what Kelly's sister is saying when they're talking to Ryan? They're saying something about Zach Braff. Okay. Here's what the three little girls say. They say, Kelly likes Zach Braff. That's what they're saying in Hindi. And they're sort of like teasing him. They were so cute and they were played by Tanvir Atwal, Ananya Kepper, and Jaysha Patel. Well, the little girl who plays Kelly's sister that says the Zach Braff line, that's Jaysha. I found her on Instagram and I reached out to her to ask her about what it was like to be on the show and she wrote back. I can't wait to share. She must be like a grown lady now. She is a grown woman now. She told me she was 13 years old when she shot this episode.
记得认识了Mindy Kaling和BJ Novak，他们对我太好了。见到Mindy Kaling对我成长过程中意义重大，因为当时我在娱乐业没看到多少印度女演员。我喜欢Mindy用她的平台所做的一切，直到今天她仍然是我巨大的灵感来源。我还记得片场所有美味的印度食物，还有整天跳舞，我记得能有机会穿上我的印度服装，我感到非常高兴。这不是很甜吗？那太棒了。当我听它的时候，我笑得合不拢嘴，因为那条信息里的一切都很可爱。我喜欢她所有的回忆。关于Mindy和Mindy所做的一切，她是完全正确的，她对很多人来说都是一种灵感。
She said she had not really heard about the show. She was still watching Disney Channel, she said. But she said her dad took her to the audition and she remembers walking into the casting office and just seeing tons of other kids who were all there for the same role. And she said the audition was just her saying that one line in Hindi and she said she didn't speak any Hindi. So her dad told her how to say it about five seconds before she went into the audition room and then she got the part. So she said she was so excited and I asked her what it was like to be on set if she had any memories and she sent back the sweetest message. So we're going to play it for you now. I remember Rainn Wilson walking up to me and shoving a lightsaber in my hand and yelling lightsaber war. I also
她说她其实没怎么听说过这部剧。她说她当时还在看迪士尼频道。但她说她爸爸带她去参加了试镜，她记得走进选角办公室时，看到成堆的孩子都在竞争同一个角色。她说试镜内容只是让她用印地语说那一句台词，而她根本不会说印地语。所以她爸爸在她进试镜室前五秒钟教了她怎么说，然后她就得到了这个角色。她说她当时非常兴奋，我问她片场是什么样的，有没有什么回忆，她发回了一条非常暖心的信息。所以我们现在就播放给你们听。我记得雷恩·威尔森走到我面前，把一把光剑塞进我手里，大喊着光剑大战。我还
remember getting to know Mindy Kaling and BJ Novak who were so sweet to me. Meeting Mindy Kaling really meant a lot to me growing up because I didn't really see many Indian actresses in the entertainment industry at that time. And I love what Mindy has done with her platform and she is still a huge inspiration for me till this day. I also remember all of the delicious Indian food on set and getting to dance all day and I remember being so happy that I had the chance to wear my Indian clothes. Isn't that so sweet? That is wonderful. That as I listened to it I was just smiling so big because that is everything about that message is lovely. I love all of her memories. She's absolutely right about Mindy and what Mindy has done and she's such an inspiration to so many
记得认识了敏迪·卡灵和BJ·诺瓦克，他们对我非常好。在成长过程中，能见到敏迪·卡灵对我意义重大，因为那时我在娱乐圈里没怎么见过印度裔女演员。我非常喜欢敏迪利用她的平台所做的一切，直到今天她仍然是我巨大的灵感来源。我还记得片场所有美味的印度食物，记得整天跳舞，也记得能有机会穿上我的印度服装让我感到非常开心。这难道不暖心吗？太棒了。我听的时候笑得合不拢嘴，因为那条信息里的每一处都非常美好。我喜欢她所有的回忆。关于敏迪以及敏迪所做的一切，她说得完全正确，敏迪确实激励了很多人。
people. Yes. Yeah. She told me after the episode aired she had classmates and family members reaching out that they had recorded it and taking pictures of her name in the credits. So that was when she was 13. She really wanted to be an actress. She said when she was 15 she decided she wanted to go into journalism and now Jayshia is the morning news reporter at NBC 15 in Mobile, Alabama. She told me she has to go to bed at four o'clock in the afternoon because she has to be in the studio at three thirty in the morning. I have always heard that about these morning anchors on the east coast that they have to get up so early. That's amazing though Jayshia. That is so cool. Isn't that so cool? She said all her co-workers know about her
人们。是的。没错。她说在剧集播出后，她的同学和家人联系她，说他们录下了节目，还拍下了片尾字幕中她的名字。那是她13岁的时候。她当时真的很想成为一名演员。她说她在15岁时决定从事新闻工作，现在Jayshia是阿拉巴马州莫比尔市NBC 15频道的早间新闻记者。她告诉我，她必须在下午四点就上床睡觉，因为她凌晨三点半就得赶到演播室。我一直听说东海岸的这些早间主播必须起得很早。不过这太棒了，Jayshia。这太酷了。这难道不酷吗？她说她所有的同事都知道她
appearance on the office and that fans will mention to her because she's Indian. They'll mention the Diwali episode and then she always like blows their mind when she says, oh no, I was in it. So I thought that was so sweet. I was in it. I say a line that offends Ryan the temp. Yes, exactly. Except he doesn't quite know he's being the butt of a joke. Right. But she said being on the office was one of her most memorable moments of her childhood. I also love that, you know, I'm sure Rain improvised going up to her with that lightsaber. There's a bunch of deleted scenes where he's fighting with kids with lightsabers and it didn't make it in. But he, he, Rain looked very much in his element. Like that's how he bonds with children. Yes.
在《办公室》中客串过，粉丝们也会因为她是印度人而向她提起。他们会提到排灯节那一集，然后当她说“哦不，我参演了那一集”时，总是让他们感到震惊。所以我认为这太可爱了。我参演了。我说了一句冒犯了临时工瑞恩的台词。是的，没错。只是他不太知道自己成了笑柄。对。但她说参演《办公室》是她童年最难忘的时刻之一。我也很喜欢这一点，你知道，我敢肯定雷恩是即兴拿着那个光剑走向她的。有很多删减片段是他和孩子们用光剑打斗的，但没能放进去。但他，他，雷恩看起来非常自在。就像那是他与孩子们建立联系的方式。是的。
Angela, should we check in on those folks at Stanford, see how they're doing? You mean the folks drinking Jagermeister? Yeah. How are they? And Angela, did you see what they ordered for dinner? Oh Jenna, you and I know firsthand. You do not drink a lot of alcohol and only eat sushi. Now, Angela, why do we know that firsthand? We know that because at the Golden Globes, was it the Golden Globes Jenna? Oh, lady, I was thinking of my Bachelorette party that you planned for me. Well, there was the Golden Globes, but the Bachelorette. Wait, have we repeated this mistake multiple times? Yes, except the second time I did better. The first time it did not work out well for me. The second time, if memory serves, sorry to say this on here,
安吉拉，我们要不要去看看斯坦福的那帮人，看看他们怎么样了？你是说那些喝野格酒的人吗？是的。他们怎么样了？还有安吉拉，你看到他们晚餐点了什么吗？哦珍娜，你和我可是亲身经历过的。你不能喝太多酒，而且只吃寿司。那么，安吉拉，我们为什么会亲身经历过呢？我们知道是因为在金球奖上，那是金球奖吗珍娜？哦，亲爱的，我当时在想你为我策划的单身派对。好吧，确实有金球奖，但单身派对……等等，我们是不是多次犯过同样的错误？是的，除了第二次我做得更好。第一次对我来说效果不太好。第二次，如果记忆没出错的话，抱歉在这里说出来，
but it hit your sister pretty hard. Yeah. Guys, Angela planned a Bachelorette party for me when I was getting married to Lee, and she took us all out for a sushi dinner. It was a fancy schmancy sushi place in Beverly Hills that I'd never eaten at. I'd only dreamed of and I was like, can we go there for my Bachelorette? They were thrilled to have us. It was so cute. All of the ladies from the office were there. All of my other friends were there. And afterwards, you took us to a dance club. Hold up, lady. We're going to get this right. First of all, the sushi place was your idea. And then after the sushi place, you guys, I got cupcakes with like her face on it. It was so cute. We had lots of free drinks sent over. The restaurant was very kind and lots of great
但这对你姐姐打击很大。是的。伙计们，当我准备和李结婚时，安吉拉为我策划了一个单身派对，她带我们所有人去吃寿司晚餐。那是比佛利山庄一家非常高档的寿司店，我以前从没去吃过。我只是梦想过，当时我说，我们能去那里办我的单身派对吗？他们很高兴能接待我们。这太可爱了。所有来自《办公室》的女士们都在那里。我所有的其他朋友也都在那里。之后，你带我们去了一家舞厅。等等，亲爱的。我们要把事情搞清楚。首先，寿司店是你的主意。然后在那之后，你们，我拿到了印有她脸的纸杯蛋糕。这太可爱了。我们收到了很多免费赠送的饮料。餐厅非常友善，还有很多很棒的
sushi. And then after the dinner, I was like, well, thank you guys. And Jenna was like, what's next? And I was like, uh, what? Wait, what? Do you not? Is this true? I do not know this. No, lady. All I had planned was the dinner. I didn't plan anything after. Is this the first time you're ever hearing of this? Yes. This is putting the dance club into perspective now because I thought at the time it was an odd choice because we've never in a million years gone clubbing. And now we were suddenly clubbing for my Bachelorette. But I was like, this is great. What a fun idea. I should say, you guys, we had a car. I got one of the big limos, you know, that we could all pile in. And I called a friend of mine who was like always kind of like, got, you know, you have that
寿司。晚餐后，我说，好吧，谢谢你们。珍娜说，接下来去哪？我说，呃，什么？等等，什么？你不知道吗？这是真的吗？我不知道这个。不，亲爱的。我只计划了晚餐。之后我什么都没计划。这是你第一次听说这件事吗？是的。这让舞厅的事现在有了眉目，因为当时我觉得这是一个奇怪的选择，因为我们从来没去过夜店。而现在我们突然为了我的单身派对去夜店了。但我当时想，这太棒了。多有趣的主意啊。我应该说，伙计们，我们有一辆车。我租了一辆大豪华轿车，你知道，我们可以挤进去。我给我的一个朋友打了电话，她总是那种，你知道，你有那种
one friend that's like, I got a hookup. I got a hookup. Yeah, I'm in the know. I called my friend Tess and I was like, Tess, um, I, I Jenna wants to go dancing. I were in Beverly Hills. What do I do? What do I do? And she was like, I'm on it. Give me like five, 10 minutes. I said, okay. So we kind of hang out a little bit. And I was like, um, I'm sorting out some stuff. I do remember hanging out on the sidewalk outside. Yes, it's because I didn't have a plan because the restaurant I had planned for was fancy sushi. And our evening would have been over at like 10 o'clock. Yeah. Anyway, I get a call from Tess and she goes, all right, Angela's pretty last minute. It's like, you know, a Thursday night in Beverly Hills. So I did get you in this one club. I know this guy,
朋友，就是那种“我有门路，我有门路”。是的，我很了解。我给我的朋友泰丝打了电话，我说，泰丝，嗯，我，珍娜想去跳舞。我们在比佛利山庄。我该怎么办？我该怎么办？她说，交给我。给我五到十分钟。我说，好的。所以我们就在那儿稍微待了一会儿。我说，嗯，我正在处理一些事情。我确实记得在外面的人行道上闲逛。是的，那是因为我没有计划，因为我计划的餐厅是高档寿司店。我们的夜晚本应在10点左右结束。是的。不管怎样，我接到泰丝的电话，她说，好吧，安吉拉，这太仓促了。你知道，这是比佛利山庄的一个周四晚上。所以我确实让你进了一家夜店。我认识那个人，
he's got a booth for you and they're going to give you drink service. It's kind of a random club, but it'll be fun. You guys can dance. Angela, it's the only time I've ever experienced bottle service. Bottle service is where you like, they bring you just bottles of alcohol and then mixers and like little cut lines to your table and you make your drink. Also, when they walk it over, everyone starts doing, at least for us, I think this was the norm because I would see different people get bottle service. And it was like, they shut off like Fetty in the air. It was so weird. It was so bizarre. They had, it was crazy dancing. I remember we got in trouble because we were dancing on top of the couches and we got reprimanded for that. But guys,
他为你准备了一个卡座，他们会提供酒水服务。这是一家有点随意的夜店，但会很有趣。你们可以跳舞。安吉拉，这是我唯一一次体验瓶装酒服务。瓶装酒服务就是他们直接给你拿来几瓶酒，然后配上调酒饮料，还有切好的小食放在你的桌子上，你自己调酒。而且，当他们走过来时，每个人都开始，至少对我们来说，我想这是常态，因为我会看到不同的人享受瓶装酒服务。就像他们往空中喷洒纸屑一样。这太奇怪了。太离谱了。他们有，那真是疯狂的舞蹈。我记得我们惹了麻烦，因为我们在沙发上跳舞，还因此受到了训斥。但是伙计们，
on our stomachs of sushi, mixed with bottle service, long story short, at the end of the night, as the limo is dropping everyone off, my sister puked in Ellie Kemper's bushes. I puked when I got home. It was in my hair. I slept in it. It was an epic night, but that's what you get when you mix sushi and a lot of booze. And that is what is in store for these guys in Stamford. Yeah. As Jenna and I rewatched this episode, I texted her and I was like, Oh, lady, alcohol and sushi. It's so true. It is so true. Should we go back to Diwali because Roy has arrived and he is watching Pam dance and have fun. And I have a full Mindy catch for you right here. And we've got a sting for it and everything. There you go. It's a full Mindy catch.
在我们的寿司胃里，混合着瓶装酒，长话短说，在夜晚结束时，当豪华轿车送每个人回家时，我姐姐在艾莉·坎珀的灌木丛里吐了。我回家时也吐了。吐在我的头发里。我带着它睡着了。那是一个史诗般的夜晚，但这就是你混合寿司和大量酒精后的下场。这就是斯坦福那帮人即将面临的。是的。当珍娜和我重看这一集时，我给她发了短信，我说，哦，亲爱的，酒精和寿司。太真实了。太真实了。我们要回到排灯节吗？因为罗伊到了，他正在看帕姆跳舞玩乐。我这里有一个完整的明迪捕捉时刻给你。我们甚至为此准备了一个音效。给你。这是一个完整的明迪捕捉。
Mira during wrote in to say at the Diwali party when Roy walks in, Beyonce's crazy love is playing in the background. And Angela, this was a note in the script. Mindy wrote in what song would be playing when Roy walks in and that it would be a Beyonce song. So I think this is a full, full Mindy. I love it. It's a very subtle full Mindy. It's like full Mindy when you don't even see Mindy, but her presence is still there. Exactly. And you know, my dance partner, we talked about this in the interview with Mindy, my dance partner Valley. Okay, he was well known by the writers because he was a writer on my name is Earl at the time. And he went on to write on 30 Rock and was one of the executive producers of modern family. Oh my gosh. I know that Mindy did say guys, he
Mira在写信时说，在排灯节派对上，当罗伊走进来时，背景里正在播放碧昂丝的《Crazy in Love》。安吉拉，这是剧本里的一个备注。明迪写下了罗伊走进来时应该播放什么歌，而且必须是碧昂丝的歌。所以我认为这是一个非常完整的明迪时刻。我喜欢它。这是一个非常微妙的完整明迪时刻。就像当你甚至没看到明迪，但她的存在感依然在那里时，那就是完整明迪。没错。而且你知道，我的舞伴，我们在采访明迪时谈到了这一点，我的舞伴瓦利。好吧，他被编剧们所熟知，因为他当时是《愚人善事》的编剧。后来他去写了《我为喜剧狂》，还是《摩登家庭》的执行制片人之一。天哪。我知道明迪确实说过，伙计们，他
wasn't an actor. He was like a friend of ours. That's so wild. Well, can I ask you a little bit about your dance moves there, Miss Fisher? You can. What are you going to say? I've danced with you. And I can tell you right now, folks, that was not a choreographed dance routine. That was just Jenna being Jenna. Yeah, we had a fan question from Zaria Collins who asked that same question. Were those dance moves choreographed? Oh, no. Oh, no. That's all Miss Fisher. That's me fully dancing with my heart and soul. That's hello, St. Louis. St. Louis prom. That sounds a Scranton right there. That's the same girl who made a sounds of Scranton playlist, everyone. There I am. You could almost rewind me and put me in my high school gym right there.
不是演员。他就像我们的一个朋友。这太疯狂了。好吧，我可以问你一点关于你的舞步吗，费舍尔小姐？你可以问。你想说什么？我和你跳过舞。我可以现在就告诉大家，那不是编排好的舞蹈动作。那只是珍娜在做珍娜自己。是的，我们有一个来自Zaria Collins的粉丝提问，她问了同样的问题。那些舞步是编排好的吗？哦，不。哦，不。那全是费舍尔小姐。那是我全心全意在跳舞。那是你好，圣路易斯。圣路易斯舞会。听起来就像斯克兰顿。那就是制作了“斯克兰顿之声”播放列表的同一个女孩，大家。我在这儿。你几乎可以倒带，把我放回我高中的体育馆里。
Well, something is going to happen that is super awkward, because that is Michael's way. Michael's way is to take a wonderful moment and make everyone cringe. And the Diwali was going to be no exception. He has this amazing scene with Mindy's parents that play Kelly's parents, which we already talked about. And he's so inspired by their love. He's going to do it. Yeah. He's going to do it. Their commitment. Yeah. He's going to propose to Carol in front of a whole room of strangers on their ninth date. Yes. She's like, Carol, will you do me the honor of making me your husband? Of making me your husband? And she's like, can we talk about this in private? And this is one of my favorite moments in movies and TV where he's like, what?
好吧，有些事情会发生，非常尴尬，因为那是迈克尔的风格。迈克尔的风格就是把一个美好的时刻变成让每个人都感到尴尬的场面。排灯节也不例外。他和明迪的父母（扮演凯利的父母）有一场精彩的戏，我们已经谈过了。他被他们的爱深深打动了。他要做了。是的。他要做了。他们的承诺。是的。他要在第九次约会时，在满屋子陌生人面前向卡罗尔求婚。是的。他说，卡罗尔，你愿意给我这个荣幸，让我成为你的丈夫吗？让我成为你的丈夫吗？她说，我们能私下谈谈吗？这是我在电影和电视中最喜欢的时刻之一，他说，什么？
Into a microphone. She's like, can we talk about it in private? And then he's like, oh, man. Oh, crap. Well, they have this scene out in the parking lot, Jenna. And it made me laugh so hard that, you know, Carol is like, I can't do this, Michael. I can't do it. And his last ditch effort, his last few moments, what is he going to say that might change her mind? He's going to go for it. What could he say to change this woman's mind? Do you know what he says? Let me come with you. I have this book, The Kama Sutra. She says, exactly. Good night, Michael. Well, at this point, Pam is, she's talking to Valley and she's realizing something. She wants to reach out to Jim. So she's going to,
对着麦克风。她说，我们能私下谈谈吗？然后他说，哦，天哪。哦，糟糕。好吧，他们在停车场有一场戏，珍娜。这让我笑得太厉害了，你知道卡罗尔说，我不能这样做，迈克尔。我不能。他最后的努力，他最后的时刻，他会说什么来改变她的主意？他要豁出去了。他能说什么来改变这个女人的主意？你知道他说了什么吗？让我跟你一起去。我有这本书，《爱经》。她说，没错。晚安，迈克尔。好吧，此时帕姆正在和瓦利交谈，她意识到了一些事情。她想联系吉姆。所以她要，
she's going to text Jim. Well, that thing happened. That thing happened, which is, you know, this, this crazy moment just happened. And who does she want to share it with? Right? This is how you know you really care about someone. Your person out there, folks, is the person you want to tell everything to right after it happens. It's who you bounce everything off of. And Pam wants to tell her person what just happened. But she runs into Angela. She needs to get her shoes. And there is Angela guarding the shoes, she says. Well, and eating her dry naan. By the way, Angela, fan question from rainy Greg, was the naan dry? No. Was it actually dry? It wasn't. It was perfectly fine. I would say that too.
她要给吉姆发短信。好吧，那件事发生了。那件事发生了，就是，你知道，这个疯狂的时刻刚刚发生。她想和谁分享呢？对吧？这就是你如何知道你真的很在乎某人。伙计们，你的那个人，就是你在事情发生后最想告诉的人。是你和谁分享一切。帕姆想告诉她的人刚刚发生了什么。但她遇到了安吉拉。她需要拿回她的鞋子。她说，安吉拉正在看守鞋子。好吧，还在吃她干巴巴的馕。顺便说一句，安吉拉，来自Rainy Greg的粉丝提问，馕是干的吗？不。它真的干吗？不是。它非常好。我也会那么说。
I ate some of that naan. It was wonderful. I was glad to have it. I was probably hungry. Well, Jen and I used to always get so tickled to have scenes together because it rarely happened. So we were really excited about this. I loved shooting the scene with you. And I love it so much. I just want us to play it. Sam, can you play it? It's hot in there. How's the naan dry? Looked like you were having fun. I am. You should come dance with us. I have to watch our shoes so they don't get stolen. Who are you texting? No one. But also, lady, my character is so nosy. So, who are you texting? Yeah, it looked like you were having fun. Who are you texting? I mean, who am I to ask you who you're texting? You're the party police. Also, you're single. Dwight made
我吃了一些那个馕。它很棒。我很高兴能吃到它。我可能饿了。好吧，珍娜和我过去总是很高兴能一起演戏，因为这种情况很少发生。所以我们对此非常兴奋。我喜欢和你拍那场戏。我太喜欢它了，我只想让我们播放它。萨姆，你能播放吗？里面很热。馕怎么会干？看起来你玩得很开心。我是。你应该来和我们一起跳舞。我得看着我们的鞋子，以免它们被偷。你在给谁发短信？没谁。但话说回来，亲爱的，我的角色太爱管闲事了。所以，你在给谁发短信？是的，看起来你玩得很开心。你在给谁发短信？我是说，我算老几啊，问你在给谁发短信？你是派对警察。而且，你是单身。德怀特做了
this big announcement that he's single. I don't know. Maybe you're texting Dwight. What's happening? Angela's spinning out in this episode. And a lot of those scenes ended up getting deleted, but it would be a fun watch to go back and watch them because that is why you are so intense in this episode. So now Pam is going to make it outside. She hasn't received a text back from Jim and she sits with Michael. Michael tries to relate to her. He's like, wow, they're both victims of broken engagements. And Pam's like, well, I mean, except that you were never actually engaged, but whatever. She tries to bond with Michael. And of course, he does that thing that you were just talking about where he just takes it one step too far. And he starts to lean in
这个大声明，说他是单身。我不知道。也许你在给德怀特发短信。发生了什么？安吉拉在这一集中有点失控。很多场景最终被删减了，但回去看它们会很有趣，因为这就是为什么你在这一集中表现得如此强烈。所以现在帕姆要走到外面。她没有收到吉姆的回复短信，她和迈克尔坐在一起。迈克尔试图与她产生共鸣。他说，哇，他们都是订婚破裂的受害者。帕姆说，好吧，我是说，除了你从来没有真正订婚过，但随便吧。她试图与迈克尔建立联系。当然，他做了你刚才说的那件事，他做得太过分了。他开始凑近
like he's going to kiss her. So awkward. We got a lot of mail about it, Angela. Ruby, Alexandra, and Vanessa Ortiz all wrote in to ask if that was a scripted moment when Michael tries to kiss Pam. What was it like? It was scripted, you guys. That was in the script. And then the thing, that great line that Pam has where she says, I'm rejecting your kiss. He's like, she's like, what are you doing? He's like, what are you doing? She's like, I'm rejecting your kiss. That's what I'm doing. Yeah. What are you doing? That was all scripted. And Angela, I was so excited to do that scene because I remember staying late that evening and shooting outside. I talked about this before when I had that scene with John up on the roof
好像要吻她。太尴尬了。我们收到了很多关于此的邮件，安吉拉。Ruby、Alexandra和Vanessa Ortiz都写信问迈克尔试图吻帕姆的那一刻是否是剧本安排的。那是什么感觉？那是剧本安排的，伙计们。剧本里就是这么写的。然后那件事，帕姆那句很棒的台词，她说，我拒绝你的吻。他说，她像说，你在做什么？他说，你在做什么？她说，我拒绝你的吻。这就是我在做的。是的。你在做什么？那全是剧本安排的。安吉拉，我非常兴奋能拍那场戏，因为我记得那天晚上留得很晚，在外面拍摄。我之前谈过，当我和约翰在屋顶上拍那场戏时，
where Pam and Jim eat the grilled cheese sandwiches. It was one of those warm summer evenings in Los Angeles. They're the best. This was another one of those. And it's one of my fondest memories from shooting the show because I got Steve all to myself and I got Miguel Arte to all to myself. And Mindy was there. And it was just us doing this scene, getting it just perfect. It felt like we had all the time in the world. There was no rush. And I just absolutely loved it. Yeah. Well, Mindy mentioned, you know, that she was kind of jealous of her parents, that they got to have this great scene with Steve because there are several characters, myself included, that rarely got to have one-on-one scenes with Steve. It just wouldn't make sense
帕姆和吉姆在那里吃烤奶酪三明治。那是洛杉矶温暖夏夜中的一个。那是最好的。这是另一个。这是我拍摄这部剧时最美好的回忆之一，因为我独享了史蒂夫，也独享了米格尔·阿特塔。明迪也在那里。我们只是在做这场戏，把它拍得完美。感觉我们有全世界的时间。没有匆忙。我绝对喜欢它。是的。好吧，明迪提到，你知道，她有点嫉妒她的父母，他们能和史蒂夫有这场精彩的戏，因为有几个角色，包括我在内，很少有机会和史蒂夫演对手戏。这在剧中的世界里根本说不通。
in the world of the show. And whenever I did, it felt so special. And I think you got to have some amazing scenes with him throughout the course of the show. And this is just one of those that was just beautiful and so fun and funny and cringy and heartfelt. Just all of it. That's all true. Angela, we did have someone write in with an old tech alert that I thought you would have pushed me. Hit me up. How'd I miss it? What is it? Kayla Whitehead said, Pam's cell phone is such old tech. But she's like, but also when she walks outside, Michael sees her on the steps and he notices that she's holding her phone and he says, expecting a call. She was like, no one would say that to you today. If you have your phone in your
每当我这样做时，感觉都非常特别。我认为你在整部剧的过程中确实和他有一些精彩的对手戏。这只是其中之一，非常美丽、有趣、尴尬且感人。就是这样。那都是真的。安吉拉，我们确实有人写信提到了一个旧技术警报，我想你会推我的。联系我。我怎么错过了？是什么？Kayla Whitehead说，帕姆的手机是如此古老的技术。但她说，还有，当她走到外面时，迈克尔在台阶上看到了她，他注意到她拿着手机，他说，在等电话吗？她说，今天没人会那样对你说。如果你今天手里拿着手机，
hand today, no one's like expecting a call because we always all have our phones in our hand. That is a brilliant catch. I am applauding that catch. I love that observation. That is an amazing observation because back then, yeah, your phone was in your purse. It was, we didn't walk around holding phones like flip phones like that because we did hardly anything with them other than talk to someone. So if you're holding it, you'd probably just spoke to someone or you were about to. Yes. That is a great observation. Pretty great. Well, I want to take us back to Stanford because I think there is a moment in this episode that is the happiest we have seen Andy since he has appeared on the show. It's happy Andy. I want to share happy Andy with you.
没人会说“在等电话”，因为我们总是手里拿着手机。这是一个绝妙的发现。我为这个发现鼓掌。我喜欢那个观察。这是一个惊人的观察，因为那时，是的，你的手机在你的钱包里。它确实在，我们不会像那样拿着翻盖手机走来走去，因为除了和某人通话外，我们几乎不用它们做什么。所以如果你拿着它，你可能刚和某人通过话，或者正准备通话。是的。这是一个伟大的观察。相当棒。好吧，我想带我们回到斯坦福，因为我认为这一集中有一个时刻是安迪自出现在剧中以来我们见过的最快乐的时刻。是快乐的安迪。我想和你分享快乐的安迪。
Happy Andy happens at around 15 minutes. They have had a lot of Yeager. Karen though, she's just tossing her Yeager shots into the trash. No one knows it. She's not getting wasted. And Andy starts singing acapella. Karen's like, no acapella Andy, but he's drunk and he's singing the indigo girls closer to fine. And as he drunkenly sings, all of a sudden, Jim, who's super wasted, starts joining in and singing. And it's so adorable. Andy's like, tuna, are you kidding me? He's so happy. He's so happy. They're having like an acapella moment. And this is happy Andy. He is thrilled. Well, Angela, we had a fan catch for Renata Torres. She says, at 17 minutes 58 seconds, you can see a pair of white flip flops under Karen's death.
快乐的安迪出现在大约15分钟时。他们喝了很多野格酒。不过凯伦，她只是把她的野格酒杯扔进垃圾桶。没人知道。她没有喝醉。安迪开始唱阿卡贝拉。凯伦说，不要阿卡贝拉，安迪，但他喝醉了，他在唱Indigo Girls的《Closer to Fine》。当他醉醺醺地唱着时，突然，超级醉的吉姆开始加入并一起唱。这太可爱了。安迪说，金枪鱼，你在开玩笑吗？他太快乐了。他太快乐了。他们就像有一个阿卡贝拉时刻。这就是快乐的安迪。他非常激动。好吧，安吉拉，我们有一个来自Renata Torres的粉丝发现。她说，在17分58秒，你可以看到凯伦的桌子下有一双白色人字拖。
And she wanted to know if that was on purpose, but we know why those are there. We do. Those were Rashida's flip flops. Yeah. The wardrobe department would give us Uggs or flip flops to wear to and from our trailers and set. So we didn't have to walk in our kind of like high heel office shoes, right? Yeah. Yes. You caught Rashida's flip flops. You know, wardrobe actually told me one time also our trailers were not close to the soundstage. It was a little, you know, quite a walk. And they said that also they would take our shoes to protect our shoes because if we walked across the parking lot back and forth and sometimes if there was weather of any kind, they preferred actually to leave our shoes on set by our desks rather than
她想知道那是否是故意的，但我们知道它们为什么在那里。我们知道。那是拉什达的人字拖。是的。服装部门会给我们UGG靴子或人字拖，让我们穿在往返拖车和片场之间。这样我们就不用穿着那种高跟办公鞋走路了，对吧？是的。是的。你发现了拉什达的人字拖。你知道，服装部门有一次也告诉我，我们的拖车离摄影棚不近。那有一段，你知道，相当长的路。他们说，他们也会拿走我们的鞋子来保护它们，因为如果我们穿过停车场来回走动，有时如果天气不好，他们实际上更喜欢把我们的鞋子留在片场的桌子旁，而不是
us walking around in them all the time. And we were delighted because that meant less time in heels. We had our travel shoes. Those were Rashida's travel shoes. Well, as they're leaving for the night in Stanford, Jim is going to ride that bike home. He's going to ride his bike home. Or is he? Well, yeah, he falls over. Well, you know, it's the end of the night at Stanford. They've had Jaeger. They've bonded over indigo girls. I mean, Andy's busting out his air mattress. He's like, oh, yeah, he's staying in for the night. Jim is going to try to ride his giant bicycle with the big basket home. And he like tips over into the bushes and Karen's in her car. She's like, hold up, get in my car, drunky. And Jenna, do you remember how freaked out people
让我们一直穿着它们走来走去。我们很高兴，因为这意味着穿高跟鞋的时间更少了。我们有我们的旅行鞋。那是拉什达的旅行鞋。好吧，当他们离开斯坦福准备回家时，吉姆要骑那辆自行车回家。他要骑自行车回家。还是他会？好吧，是的，他摔倒了。好吧，你知道，这是斯坦福夜晚的结束。他们喝了野格酒。他们因为Indigo Girls建立了联系。我是说，安迪正在拿出他的充气床垫。他就像，哦，是的，他今晚要留下来。吉姆要试着骑他那辆带大篮子的巨大自行车回家。他像倾斜着摔进了灌木丛，凯伦在她的车里。她说，等等，上我的车，醉鬼。珍娜，你还记得人们对这一刻有多恐慌吗？
were about this moment? Yeah. I mean, people thought Karen was shady that she let them get so wasted and that that was she waiting for jam. She had planned it all along. Was she waiting out in the parking lot for jam? I was like, hey, Mr. Tipsy, get in my car. And remember this in this episode, it was written that they were going to like kiss. Oh, I talked to Rashida about it. I texted with her and I want to read you guys what she said. She said in this episode there, they had written a scene where Jim and Karen get sloppy drunk and make out. So maybe I guess she had been drinking too in that different version, right? In that different version, because I have the scripted version of that, they, the three of
是的。我是说，人们认为凯伦很阴险，她让他们喝得那么醉，她在等吉姆吗？她是不是一直都在计划？她是不是在停车场等吉姆？我当时想，嘿，醉醺醺先生，上我的车。记住在这一集中，剧本里写着他们要接吻。哦，我和拉什达谈过这件事。我和她发了短信，我想读给你们听听她说了什么。她说在这一集中，他们写了一场戏，吉姆和凯伦喝得烂醉如泥并亲热。所以也许我猜她在那个不同版本里也喝了酒，对吧？在那个不同版本里，因为我有那个剧本版本，他们，他们三个
them go to a bar and they all get drunk together at a bar and then they were supposed to make out on the street outside of this bar. Yeah. And Rashida said they actually filmed the scene in the parking lot. Oh, yeah. And she said she was really worried. She was like, everyone's going to hate me. And then she told me Stephen Merchant actually suggested that they cut the scene out. That he got to watch over because Stephen and Ricky would watch our episodes and they would give the producers notes rarely, but sometimes. And their notes were always correct. They were always like, they knew don't move that needle so far. Yeah. And Rashida said she felt like Stephen really understood the relationships and that this was going too far,
去了一家酒吧，他们都在酒吧里喝醉了，然后他们本应该在酒吧外面的街上亲热。是的。拉什达说他们实际上在停车场拍了那场戏。哦，是的。她说她真的很担心。她说，每个人都会讨厌我。然后她告诉我史蒂芬·莫昌特实际上建议他们删掉那场戏。他有权监督，因为史蒂芬和瑞奇会看我们的剧集，他们很少给制片人提意见，但有时会。他们的意见总是正确的。他们总是，他们知道不要把那根针拨得太远。是的。拉什达说她觉得史蒂芬真的很理解这些关系，而且这做得太过分了，
too bold, too quickly. And it would sort of sabotage anything that Jim and Karen might could possibly be as a foil for Pam. It was just too much. Yeah. I think if you wanted to believe in their relationship, which you will, like Jim and Karen are going to really have a great relationship, you don't want it to start off with like a sloppy drunk make out parking on the side of the street. Kids, are you listening? Nothing good happens after midnight. Okay. Go home. This is what aunt told me when I went off to college. She said, here's my advice to you about sleeping around. This is what she said. She said, you're going to go to these parties. You're going to do some drinking and you might in the moment want to make a decision that's
太大胆，太快了。这会破坏吉姆和凯伦作为帕姆的陪衬可能拥有的任何东西。这太过分了。是的。我想如果你想相信他们的关系，你会的，就像吉姆和凯伦真的会有一段很棒的关系，你不想让它以在街边停车场烂醉如泥的亲热开始。孩子们，你们在听吗？午夜过后没好事。好吧。回家吧。这就是我上大学时阿姨告诉我的。她说，这是我关于乱搞给你的建议。这就是她说的。她说，你要去参加这些派对。你要喝点酒，你可能会在当下想要做一个决定，那是
impulsive. She said, my advice to you is go home because you can always wake up in the morning and say, oh, I wish I'd slept with that guy and you can do something about it. But you can't undo. You can't undo. Yeah. I'm with your aunt. You can't undo. But I was kind of lame in college. When I turned 21, I had a big paper due for a class I was taking. And all my friends were like, you're going to go out it's your 21st birthday. And I said, oh, no, I need to work on my paper. So I worked on my paper and my dad had a Texaco gas card and he would pay my Texaco gas card. Just like reality bites, I would go to that gas station and I would get gas, bread, sandwich, meat, potato chips, soda, like everything. And I went to Texaco and I bought
冲动的。她说，我的建议是回家，因为你总能在早上醒来说，哦，我真希望我和那个家伙睡了，你可以做点什么。但你不能撤销。你不能撤销。是的。我同意你阿姨的。你不能撤销。但我上大学时有点笨。当我21岁时，我有一篇重要的论文要交。我所有的朋友都说，你要出去玩，这是你的21岁生日。我说，哦，不，我需要写我的论文。所以我写了我的论文，我爸爸有一张德士古加油卡，他会付我的德士古加油卡。就像《现实的创痛》一样，我会去那个加油站，我会买汽油、面包、三明治肉、薯片、苏打水，就像所有东西。我去了德士古，我给自己买了一瓶
myself a Coronita. It's not even the big Corona. It's a Coronita because I was 21 and I went and I worked on my term paper and I had my Coronita. And that was my 21st birthday. That is literally adorable. That is adorable. I was a big dork lady. That's why we would have been friends. I would hang out with you and your cat. We would have been besties. This is also why as adults, we mixed sushi with a lot of hard liquor because we didn't learn in college. We didn't learn. Where are we at? I don't even know where we're at, except that Karen put Jim in his car. And now we go back to Diwali and it's one of my favorite moments ever. Dwight and Michael are going to perform a cover of Adam Sandler's Hanukkah song dedicated to Indians everywhere. Yes, the crowd loves it.
科罗娜小瓶装。甚至不是大瓶的科罗娜。是科罗娜小瓶装，因为我21岁了，我去写我的学期论文，我喝了我的科罗娜小瓶装。那就是我的21岁生日。这简直太可爱了。这太可爱了。我当时是个大书呆子，亲爱的。这就是为什么我们会成为朋友。我会和你还有你的猫一起玩。我们会成为最好的朋友。这也是为什么作为成年人，我们把寿司和大量烈酒混合在一起，因为我们在大学里没学到。我们没学到。我们现在在哪？我甚至不知道我们在哪，除了凯伦把吉姆放进了她的车里。现在我们回到排灯节，这是我最喜欢的时刻之一。德怀特和迈克尔要表演亚当·桑德勒的《光明节之歌》的翻唱版，献给各地的印度人。是的，观众很喜欢。
Angela, so many people wrote in asking about this song. Was it improvised? A lot of people thought that because Steve was holding a piece of paper that maybe we wrote this on the fly. No, this was in the script. And in fact, Kent told me it had been in the script as far back as the pre-table draft. This is kind of a writer's term, but they send out a draft of the script before they let anyone see it and they have to give it to all of the main producers so that they can start planning wardrobe and locations. And Kent said that at that pre-table draft, this was the tag for the episode and it remained there until we shot it. So they got permission and all that kind of stuff. And he said, Steve asked for that piece of paper because he felt like his character wrote it at the party
安吉拉，很多人写信问这首歌。是即兴创作的吗？很多人认为因为史蒂夫拿着一张纸，也许我们是临时写的。不，这是剧本里的。事实上，肯特告诉我，早在预读剧本草稿时，它就在剧本里了。这是一种编剧术语，但在他们让任何人看到之前，他们会发出一份剧本草稿，他们必须把它交给所有的主要制片人，以便他们可以开始规划服装和地点。肯特说，在那个预读草稿中，这就是这一集的标签，直到我们拍摄时它一直都在那里。所以他们得到了许可之类的东西。他说，史蒂夫要了那张纸，因为他觉得他的角色是在派对上写的，
and that would sell the idea that this was like a last minute idea by Michael. Yeah, yeah. I thought the same thing. I thought Michael, Michael needed those notes. Steve did not. Right. Yeah. Well, it's so good. And I have a really great catch. I'm going to call it a BFF catch. What is it? At 20 minutes, 34 seconds after he's finished singing and it pans to the crowd and everyone cheers, you and I are sitting side by side on the floor together. Oh my gosh, Angela, you know we did that ourselves. I know. We sat together. We probably were, I mean, I remember them doing that song. We were all just elated and along for the ride. It was so fun. And I think we, I think we just sat next to each other because they probably weren't even sure if they were going
那会卖掉这是一个迈克尔临时起意的想法。是的，是的。我也这么想。我想迈克尔，迈克尔需要那些笔记。史蒂夫不需要。对。是的。好吧，这太好了。我有一个非常棒的发现。我要称之为BFF发现。是什么？在20分34秒，在他唱完后，镜头扫向人群，每个人都在欢呼，你和我并排坐在地板上。天哪，安吉拉，你知道那是我们自己做的。我知道。我们坐在一起。我们可能，我是说，我记得他们唱那首歌。我们都欣喜若狂，沉浸其中。这太有趣了。我想我们，我想我们只是坐在彼此旁边，因为他们可能甚至不确定他们是否要
to use that big swing back to the crowd. Right? Yeah. And so there we are. There we are on the ground next to each other. BFF catch. That is the perfect way to end this podcast episode of Diwali. We did it with a BFF catch. We did it. And thank you so much to Mindy Kaling for stopping by. I just felt like we could kept talking and talking and I can't wait for her to come back. And if you guys get a chance, go check out Mindy's new show that she co-created with Lang Fisher. It's so cute. It's a coming of age kind of comedy drama called Never Have I Ever. And the cast is wonderful and the writing is great. And you guys, if you watch it, you'll see Angela on it because Angela's in it in a couple of episodes. Yes, I'm in two episodes.
使用那个扫向人群的大镜头。对吧？是的。所以我们就在那儿。我们就在地上，彼此旁边。BFF发现。这是结束这一集排灯节播客的完美方式。我们用一个BFF发现做到了。我们做到了。非常感谢明迪·卡灵的到来。我只是觉得我们可以一直聊下去，我迫不及待想让她回来。如果你们有机会，去看看明迪和兰·费舍尔共同创作的新剧。它太可爱了。这是一部关于成长的喜剧剧情片，叫《好想做一次》。演员阵容很棒，剧本也很棒。伙计们，如果你们看了，你们会看到安吉拉在里面，因为安吉拉在几集中都有客串。是的，我在两集中。
I play the mom. I play one of her nemesis's mom and it was really fun. I'll be the mom all day long, Jenna. I know. Yeah. Casting folks out there. If you need a mom with a little bit of sass, give me a call. You know where to go. Guys, thank you so much. This was a really fun one and we will be back next week with Branch Wars. See you then. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher, our sound engineer is Sam Peefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Gratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episodes Candy Bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of StitcherPremium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我演妈妈。我演她其中一个宿敌的妈妈，这真的很有趣。我整天都可以演妈妈，珍娜。我知道。是的，选角的朋友们。如果你需要一个有点个性的妈妈，给我打电话。你知道去哪找我。伙计们，非常感谢。这是一个非常有趣的节目，我们下周会带着《分部战争》回来。到时候见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的制片人是科迪·费舍尔，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·皮弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·格拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。如需无广告版本的节目和我们的奖励剧集《Candy Bag》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需StitcherPremium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码Office。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。